hey this is Andrew Brown your Cloud
instructor in exam Pro and I'm bringing
you another complete study course and
this time it's the Microsoft 365
fundamentals course made available to
you here by freecocab so this course is
designed to help you pass and achieve
the MS 900 Microsoft 365 fundamental
certification and the way that we're
going to do that is by going through
lots of lecture content and doing follow
alongs in your own account we've got a
full free practice exam so you can
simulate the real exam and we've got
cheat sheets on the day of the exam that
you can use and cram that last minute
knowledge so you pass the exam take that
certification and prove on your resume
or LinkedIn you have that Microsoft 365
knowledge and get that job or promotion
you've been looking for just a bit about
myself I was previously the CTO of
multiple Ed tech companies with 15 years
industry experience five years
specializing in the cloud I'm in a WS
Community hero I've published many many
free Cloud certification courses just
like this one and I love Star Trek and
coconut water I just want to take a
moment attack viewers like you for
making these free courses possible
because the two who buy our additional
study material that allow us to produce
these free courses if you're looking for
more ways of supporting more free
courses just like this one the best way
is to sign up on exampro.com and in
particular for this certification it's
ms-900 to get that additional study
material there you can get study notes
flash cards quizlets downloadable
lecture notes which are the slides to
all the lecture videos downloadable
cheat sheets practice exams you can ask
questions and get learning support and
more and just by signing up for free
you're going to get that free practice
exam and cheat sheets with no credit
card required and no trial limit so if
there are updates of this course the
best way is to look on the YouTube and
to see if there has been an update
you'll click that and that's where
you're going to see things like
Corrections additions and modifications
to make sure you are using the latest
version of this course and to keep up to
date for upcoming courses the best way
is to follow me on Twitter at Andrew
Brown and if you do pass the exam or
you'd like to know or would like to
suggest what course to be produced Next
you can go tell me that on Twitter
[Music]
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we're at
the start of our journey asking the most
important question first which is what
is the ms-900 Microsoft 365 fundamentals
so the Microsoft 365 fundamentals is an
entry-level Microsoft certification it
has absolutely no prerequisites so you
don't need to have any prior cloud or
SAS knowledge to learn this specific
course the course teaches the cloud
fundamentals such as Cloud Concepts
types of cloud computing and the
benefits of migrating to a cloud
environment compared to an on-premises
infrastructure the core Microsoft 365
services and Concepts we'll be going
through the Microsoft 365 solutions that
improve productivity facilitate
collaboration and optimize
Communications such as SharePoint online
Microsoft Viva and Microsoft teams we'll
cover topics related to the endpoint and
deployment options in Microsoft 365 like
Microsoft endpoint manager Azure virtual
desktop and windows as a service
security compliance privacy and Trust in
Microsoft 365 like multi-factor
education and Defender 365 and we'll
cover the Microsoft 365 pricing of
subscriptions licenses and support
offerings for services here's a simple
definition of what Microsoft 365 is so
Microsoft 365 formerly Office 365 is the
line of subscription services offered by
Microsoft which adds to and includes the
Microsoft Office product line it's a
superset of Office 365 with Windows 10
Enterprise licenses and other
cloud-based security and device
management products so who is this
certification for well you should be
considering the Microsoft 365
fundamental certification if you are new
to cloud and want to learn the
fundamentals and benefits of adopting
cloud services in general and the
software as a service Cloud Model
specifically you are a business user
administrator or IT professional you
want to understand the capabilities of
Microsoft 365 and how to build basic
Solutions and deploy cloud services in
your organization you are a senior Cloud
engineer or Microsoft 360 C5
administrator who needs to reset or
refresh their knowledge after working
for multiple years so now let's take a
look at the Microsoft 365 certification
roadmap to see where we would go after
the Microsoft 365 fundamentals and what
kind of roles would be associated with
those certifications so at the start you
get your Microsoft 365 fundamentals
which is at the fundamental level after
that we have the associate level
certifications such as the modern
desktop administrator teams
administrator developer or Security
administrator it's really up to you to
choose which field you're interested in
a common route would be something like
taking the modern desktop administrator
at the associate level then moving to
the Enterprise administrator at the
expert level it's also common for people
to take multiple of these associate
level certifications it doesn't have to
be just one this is to ensure they have
a wide range of knowledge on all of
these areas for possible career openings
also if you find the cloud to be really
cool and interesting you have options
such as Azure administrator and Azure
developer from there you you could
possibly take the Azure Solutions
architect or devops engineer at the
expert level so you see there are
several options for you to choose from
and these are not all the ones on the
list once again it's up to you to decide
what you want to specialize in and there
is no perfect route but these are just a
few suggestions for you to decide on
your own so how long is it going to take
to pass this certification well it's
going to really depend on your
background but if we had to generalize
it we can look at it as kind of a scale
and so if you are at the beginner level
you're looking at roughly 15 hours and
when we say beginner we're saying
someone that has never used Microsoft
365 or Office Products like OneDrive
teams SharePoint purview Etc someone
that has never used Microsoft Azure or
any cloud provider or someone that has
no Tech background or experience and
when we're looking at the other side of
the Spectrum which is someone that is
experienced we're looking at somebody
who can watch this at 1.5 to 2 times
speed and are able to absorb this
information very quickly so they have
practical working experience with
Microsoft 365 and is very familiar with
using them they have experience with
Microsoft Azure or any cloud provider
like a WS or gcp so they can easily
translate that knowledge or they have a
strong background in technology where
they've worked in the industry for many
years and so you know their study time
is going to be a lot shorter at five
hours or less and so on average most
people are going to take about 10 hours
to study for this course and when we
talk about the kind of stuff you'll be
doing it's going to be 50 lecture in
labs and we call them follow-ons where
the idea is you follow along in your own
account and then 50 is the practice
exams so if you look at the length of
the content which is around four hours
then you know you should spend as much
time doing practice exams to pass and
the recommended time to study is about
one to two hours a day for roughly eight
days so what kind of effort are we going
to have to put in to pass the exam well
you have the watch the lecture videos
and memorize key information you'll need
to do Hands-On labs and follow along
with your own account although as a
fundamental certification the
certification is not very heavy on hands
on material but it will still provide a
much greater understanding of the topics
you'll need to know for the exam and you
will need paid online practice exams
that simulate the real exam and the last
two here were things that I used to
never suggest because you could
literally just watch the videos and pass
however Microsoft has recently updated
this exam so it's more difficult and so
for these last two points you do have to
do these two things for the paid online
practice exams that can be hard for some
people so I've made it easier for you by
providing you with a full free practice
exam on exampro.co ms-900 and so you
just have to sign up with no credit card
required and you'll get a full set of
questions that simulate the real exam so
for the contents of the exam it is
composed of four domains and each domain
has its own weighting which determines
how many questions in a domain that will
appear so for domain one which is cloud
Concepts we're looking at 10 to 15
percent for domain two core Microsoft
365 services and concept tips we should
expect 50 to 55 percent of the questions
from there this is where the most amount
of questions are from for domain three
security compliance privacy and Trust in
Microsoft 365 we're sitting at around 15
to 20 percent of the questions and for
domain four Microsoft 365 pricing and
support we have roughly 10 to 15 percent
of the questions so just to emphasize
for domain two you will need to know a
wide range of the core Microsoft 365
services but you also need to know in
depth about the core services so where
do you take the exam well at an
in-person test center or online from the
convenience of your own home Microsoft
has partnered with the test center
Network Pearson View and it offers in
person or online and these exams are
proctored meaning there is somebody
watching you to ensure that you are not
cheating in order to pass the exam you
have to score 700 points out of a
thousand and so 700 generally equates to
70 percent but it's around 70 percent
because Microsoft uses scaled soaring
meaning that they could adjust it based
on how many people are passing or
failing so always aim to get higher than
70 percent the exam contains 43 to 50
questions so you can afford to get
roughly 10 to 12 questions wrong there
is no penalty for wrong questions like
minus one so you should always choose an
answer and the questions come in a few
formats multiple choice multiple answer
drag and drop and yes or no questions
the duration of the exam is one hour or
60 minutes so you have a little more
than one minute per question the exam
time is 60 minutes but the seat time is
90 minutes see time refers to the amount
of time to review instructions Show
online Proctor your workspace read and
accept NDA and complete the exam and
provide feedback and when you do pass
the exam the exam is valid forever
Microsoft's fundamental level exams do
not expire and you do not need to do a
recertification so that about covers the
introduction of the course
foreign
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going through an exam guide
breakdown of the Microsoft 365
fundamental certification so the first
thing you want to do is to go to this
link here
docs.microsoft.com and dash us slash
certifications slash exams slash ms-900
and once you're here you want to
navigate to this link called Ms 900
study guide this will open a neatly
organized study guide that Microsoft has
prepared for us for the Microsoft 365
fundamentals exam we've already covered
a general overview on what the exam is
who the exam is for and a brief overview
on the topics but we'll need to cover
the exam breakdown in more detail this
is the section we're looking for the
objective domain skills the exam
measures so we already covered the four
main domains describe Cloud Concepts
describe core Microsoft 365 services and
concepts with the emphasis of 50 to 55
percent describe security compliance
privacy and Trust in Microsoft 365 disc
Microsoft 365 pricing and support I
won't be going through the entire list
because it's quite long but I'll point
out the ones I know for sure will be on
the exam starting with Microsoft SAS iOS
and pass offerings the differences
between Office 365 Microsoft 365 and
Windows 365 you'll need to know public
private and hybrid scenarios and compare
advantages of cloud-based Services
versus on-premises services for the core
Microsoft 365 services and Concepts
you'll definitely need to know all of
these Services listed you'll need to
know a brief description of what it is
when it's used for some of its key
features how does it improve
productivity or collaboration
Etc I'll just point out the ones I saw
mentioned a lot on the exam so Microsoft
Outlook and Microsoft Exchange Microsoft
365 apps in OneDrive Microsoft teams
SharePoint the ever and Microsoft Viva
there will definitely be some questions
on Microsoft endpoint manager Windows
365 Cloud PC and Azure virtual desktop
deployment and release models for
Windows as a service including
deployment Rings Viva insights and
you'll definitely see Microsoft 365
admin Center and Microsoft 365 user
portal for the security compliance
privacy and Trust in Microsoft 365
section you'll definitely see principle
of least privileged access identity and
access management capabilities in
Microsoft 365 including Azure active
directory and Azure identity
multi-factor authentication conditional
access Microsoft 365 Defender Defender
for endpoint Defender for Office 365
Defender for identity and the Microsoft
Defender portal Microsoft secure score
Azure Sentinel service trust portal and
compliance manager DLP compliance scores
and you'll see a bit of auditing and
e-discovery solutions for the Microsoft
365 pricing and support domain pricing
model for Microsoft cloud services
including Enterprise agreements Cloud
solution providers Direct filling
available base licensing and management
options there were definitely some
questions on private public preview and
general availability options Microsoft
365 roadmap portal you'll need to know
how to create a support request for
Microsoft 365 services and you'll need
to know the service level agreements
once again there's a lot on the list so
I couldn't name all of them so name the
ones I thought were the most important
but throughout the course we'll
definitely cover all of the material in
great detail
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're starting at the beginning of
our journey asking the most fundamental
question what is cloud computing so
looking into the dictionary cloud
computing is described as the practice
of using a network of remote servers
hosted on the internet to store manage
and process data rather than a local
server or a personal computer so when
we're talking about local we describe
this as being on premise so being your
own office or your own Data Center and
this is where you own the servers you
hire the IT people you pay the rent or
the real estate you take all the risk
whereas with a cloud provider if you're
utilizing them it's someone else who
owns the servers someone else who hires
the IT people someone else who pays or
rents the real estate and you are only
left would be responsible for
configuring your cloud services and code
and someone else takes care of the rest
sounds great doesn't it so now what I
want to do is just give you a quick
overview of how servers have evolved
what we describe is cloud computing from
a technical perspective and we'll
probably dive deeper into this later in
the course but we're just going to get a
good overview here to understand from a
business perspective so way back in the
day what we had was dedicated servers if
you wanted a server to run your web app
or your technology what you had to do is
you had to go buy a single dedicated
physical machine and that was for one
specific business dedicated servers are
still used today but there's some
downsides with them they're very
expensive they're high maintenance
however you do get a great level of
customization and you potentially can
have better Security based on your use
case then what came along was virtual
private servers where we still had one
physical machine but it was still
dedicated to a single business so we
figured out how to take that physical
machine and virtualize it into sub
machines so now we can fully utilize or
better utilize that physical server with
running multiple apps we didn't have to
buy four different servers for four
different apps we could easily run four
web apps into four virtual sub machines
then we had shared hosting and this made
it a lot easier for anybody who was
building websites or wordpresses but the
idea here is that you had one physical
machine and it was shared by hundreds of
businesses so it wasn't a single
business sharing the cost it was
multiple businesses this relies on most
tenants on under utilizing the resources
though so if you had 100 people on a
server and one person use more of the
server than the others then you could
all potentially suffer from that case
but at the very least you are getting
very very cheap servers but there are
definitely some limitations so now
coming down to Cloud hosting Cloud
hosting gives us the best of both worlds
so we have multiple physical machines
that act as one system which could be
described as the cloud and that system
is extracted away into multiple cloud
services so you get flexibility and
scalability it's very secure it's very
cost effective and it's highly
configurable so that is where we're
currently at and that is generally what
cloud computing and Cloud hosting is
about
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at common cloud
services so a cloud provider can have
hundreds of cloud services that are
grouped into various types of services
and the four most common types of cloud
services for infrastructure as a service
which is a topic we will discuss about
later would be compute so this is where
you have a virtual computer that can run
applications programs and code then you
have storage so this is where you would
have a virtual hard drive that you could
store files then you in a virtual
networking because you have these
computers in storage so you need to put
them in some kind of virtual Network to
Define internet connections or network
isolations and then you have databases
so just imagine a database that is
running in the cloud or if you're not
familiar databases just imagine that
it's excel in the cloud but it Powers
your web apps one thing I want you to
know about the term cloud computing is
that even though it says Computing in
the word at this point we just use it as
a catch-all term so it could refer to
all of these categories so when I say
cloud computing it could be referring to
compute network storage and data
database but you can also say cloud
storage Cloud compute Cloud databases
Cloud networking and people will know
what you mean
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we are looking at what is Microsoft so
you've probably seen this logo before
and Microsoft is an American
multinational computer technology
corporation headquartered in Redmond
Washington Microsoft makes software
phones tablets game consoles cloud
services which is what we care about
here today and they even have a search
engine and we're not just limited to
that list they have tons of stuff but
Microsoft is best known for their
operating system called a Windows and
they've been around since the 1970s so
they've been around for quite a while in
the tech sphere so now that leads us to
the question what is azure so Azure is
what Microsoft calls their cloud service
provider and so it's called Microsoft
Azure where we commonly refer to it as
just Azure so here is the logo for it
and if you're wondering what is the name
behind the service Azure literally means
bright blue color of the cloudless sky
so that's great you'll hear me say cloud
service provider frequently throughout
the cloud Concepts portion of the course
and it is abbreviated to CSP but that's
what Azure is it is a cloud service
provider so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the benefits of
cloud computing so what are the benefits
well we have a big list here for you
starting with cost Effectiveness so you
pay for what you consume there are no
upfront costs you have pay as you go
also abbreviated as poig and you're
sharing the cost with thousands of
customers so that's how you're getting
that low cost another benefit is that
you can go Global so you can launch
workloads anywhere in the world just
choose your own region and you are now
in the global market another benefit is
that the cloud is secure because the
cloud providers take care of the
physical security and cloud services can
be secure by default or you have the
ability to configure access down to the
granular level so you have a lot of
security controls that you would have
and you would normally not have where
you'd have to build out on premises now
the cloud is also known for being
reliable so you can have data backups
disaster recovery and data replication
and fault tolerance the cloud is also
scalable you can increase or decrease
your resources and services based on the
demand the cloud is also elastic so so
you can automate scaling during spikes
and drops of the demand when there is no
longer the demand for that stuff and
finally it's also current so the
underlying hardware and managed software
is patched upgraded and replaced by the
cloud provider without interruption to
you and for the last point there are
cases of interruption but generally
fewer interruptions than you would have
on premises so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the different
types of cloud computing and we have
this nice pyramid on left hand side to
help us understand how each type builds
off the other starting at the top of our
pyramid we have software as a service
also known as SAS and this is a product
that is run and managed by the service
provider you don't have to worry about
how the service is maintained and it
just works and remains available so you
might not be aware of this but you
probably already are using a SAS product
so examples of that could be Salesforce
or Gmail or Office 365 so those are
things that would be considered SAS and
these are really for customers so it's
just you wanting to use General software
on your computer but in the cloud the
next category we have is platform as a
service abbreviated as pass and so here
we focus on the development and
management of your applications so you
don't have to worry about provisioning
configuring or understanding the
hardware or operating system and this is
really for people that are building apps
but they don't think about any of the
infrastructure services like this would
be elastic Beanstalk on a WS Heroku that
is very popular amongst Junior
developers which is a third party
service for launching web apps and then
you have the Google app engine so those
are three examples there and these are
really for developers so platform as a
service makes it easy for developers to
build apps on the cloud without worrying
about all the stuff underneath at the
bottom finally we have infrastructure as
a service abbreviated as is and this is
the basic building blocks for cloud it
so it provides access to networking
features computers and data storage
space you don't worry about the IT staff
data centers and hardware and so
examples of infrastructure as a service
would be Microsoft Azure AWS or even
Oracle cloud and so this is really
intended for administrators the main
focus of the course will be on Microsoft
365 which falls under the category of
software as a service but you will
definitely need to understand the
differences of the cloud computing types
for the exam so that is the three types
of cloud computing okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at the types of cloud
computing and responsibilities so we saw
the three categories but we don't really
understand what it is that we're
responsible for and what is the cloud
service provider responsible for so
let's lay out our categories and we're
going to include on-premises into this
because technically on premises could be
a private cloud and should be in the
category here so we have on premises
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and software as a service so
when we're looking at applications it's
going to be the customer's
responsibility for on-prem
infrastructure as a service and pass but
when we have software as a service the
cloud service provider is responsible
for that when we are looking at the data
level it's going to be the same for
software as a service the cloud service
provider is going to be responsible but
for the rest it's going to be the
customer and then on the next level for
the runtime the cloud service provider
will be responsible for the platform as
a service and software as a service the
customer will be responsible for
on-premises and infrastructure as a
service for middleware it's going to be
the same game for the OS like the
operating system that is running on the
service it's going to be the same then
we get to virtualization the cloud
service provider is responsible for the
virtualization for infrastructure as a
service platform as a service and
software is a service so everything
except for on-prem then for servers it's
the same for storage it's the same and
for networking it's also the same so you
can see that on premises you're
responsible for everything and the
farther we move up the types of cloud
computing the less responsibility you
have
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at azure's deployment
models the first model we're going to
talk about is public cloud and that's
where everything is built on the cloud
service provider you're not using
anything on-prem or in your own data
centers everything is running within
Azure generally this is known as Cloud
native that for some reason Azure calls
it the public Cloud so that's what we're
going to use in the terminology here so
here I have an architectural diagram we
have a network on Azure and within that
Network we have a virtual machine
running in a database running so that
would be an example of public Cloud then
we have private cloud and so this is
where everything is built on the
company's data also known as on premises
because it's within the premises of the
organization like their physical
location and an organization could
technically be operating their own cloud
but it would be private cloud and it
could be running an open source Cloud
software that mimics what Azure would do
such as openstack so it looks very
similar but you just put an openstack
and it's running a virtual machine or a
server and it's also running a database
and the last on our list here is how
hybrid so with hybrid you are using both
on-premises and the cloud service
provider and they're connected together
and so there's a lot of different
networking services that you can use
that will facilitate the connection
between the two in this case we're using
express route express route is a
dedicated connection it's like having a
fiber optic Line running from your
on-premises data center to the Azure
Network so it's just one of the ways you
can connect and if we wanted to
understand the pros and cons I have this
nice little table here and we'll just
quickly go through it so if you're using
public Cloud it's more cost effective
for security its screen controls are
stronger by default but some people
might not find the cloud will meet all
their security requirements because of
government and Regulatory reasons not
because the cloud is not secure but it's
just those policies for the level of
configuration it's going to be limited
based on what the cloud service provider
exposes to you so there's a lot of
configuration there it's just that if
you have your own servers you obviously
can do anything and everything with them
for technical knowledge you don't need
to have as much in-depth knowledge of
the underlying infrastructure because as
you're not physically setting up servers
or networking and everything else now
coming down to private Cloud private
cloud is the most expensive option on
our list so you're going to be paying a
lot of money for security there is no
guarantee that it is a hundred percent
secure because you just don't have the
same kind of visibility that you would
have with a cloud service provider with
all those dashboards it's just so hard
to build out all that software but you
can meet your security compliance
requirements depending on your situation
but this is becoming less and less is
more governments and larger
organizations move over to the cloud you
can configure infrastructure exactly how
you like because you literally bought
the hardware and can do anything you
want with it and for the technical
knowledge you'll require a serious
amount of technical knowledge you might
even have a really hard time finding the
resources to maintain all that stuff
down below we have the hybrid model so
this could be more cost effective based
on what you offload to the cloud and
also the cost of actually moving data
back and forth for security you have
more to secure but technically some
things are easier to secure on the cloud
than it is in private so you might have
a boost security you're going to get the
best of both worlds in terms of
configuration and for technical
knowledge you're going to need to know
both the cloud and how to set things up
on premises and that's the most work
there and just one more deployment model
here I just wanted to briefly touch on
Cross Cloud this isn't something that is
listed on the actual exam but it's
something that you should understand and
know and so cross cloud is when you're
using multiple Cloud providers some
people refer this as multi-cloud or
hybrid cloud and so I just have an
example here so there's a service called
Azure Arc and what Azure Arc does that
extends your control plane so you can
run containers kubernetes containers on
a different platforms and so you could
have a WS on the left hand side with eks
and gcp kubernetes engine and so you can
be running virtual machines and they're
all treated like they're on the same
network so cross cloud is becoming very
popular with extremely large
organizations where they have very
unique requirements but I definitely
want you to know what that is because it
just gets left out and it's definitely
something that is a part of the industry
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at the concept of
total cost of ownership also known as
TCO so what is the difference between
on-premises having your own data centers
in comparison with using Azure so you'll
notice above it it says capex and Opex
we're going to talk about that in the
next slide but for the time being we're
going to focus on the total cost of
ownership so to really make sense of TCO
I always use this graphic here and if
you're wondering what that is those are
icebergs people sometimes think they
look like teeth and so just to make this
dry a little bit more clear I've added
some penguins and a whale so there's no
mistaking it and the reason we're using
this as a representation is because we
have the top of the iceberg which are
the costs that we're generally concerned
about but then we have those hidden
costs those costs that we're not really
thinking about underneath the water and
if you know icebergs they can be really
big underneath so on the left hand side
the cost that we generally think of is
the software license fees and then for
the cloud service provider we look at
the subscription fees and so when you're
comparing these two sometimes the
subscription fees can cost more than the
software license fee so you think well
we should really just use on-premises
because it's more cost effective but
when we take in the total cost of
ownership and all the costs involved
we're going to see a very different
picture so on the left hand side if you
are on premises you have to deal with
the implementation the configuration and
the training but you also have to deal
with the physical security of your
building you have to pay for the
hardware you have to pay for the IT
personnel you also have to deal with
maintenance now on the right hand side
on the cloud you still have to do
implementation configuration and
training but that's about it so there's
a big difference in terms of what you
have to do and you might ask okay well
what is the amount of savings well
generally people find that when they
move from on-premises to the cloud they
save about 75 percent that's a lot of
money okay 75 percent of what you
generally would spend and so now all
this stuff on the left hand side is now
azure's responsibility you don't take
care of those anymore Azure is going to
take care of it for you so that's total
cost of of ownership
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at Capital versus
operational expenditure so on the left
hand side we have capex so Capital
expenditures on the right hand side we
have operational expenditures Opex and
so looking at the left hand side capital
expenditure is spending money up front
on physical infrastructure so deducting
the expenses from your tax bill over
time a lot of companies especially
larger companies are used to dealing
with capital expenses and they know how
to work their tax bill so that's why a
lot of people are afraid to move over to
the cloud because they're used to this
way of operating but let's talk about
some of the things that would be
considered a capital expense so again
it's anything that's physical and then
you're buying it with money up front so
computers that would be your server cost
if you were to buy hard drives it'd be
your storage costs if you bought routers
cables or switches for your network if
you're purchasing things for backup and
archive costs if you had disaster
recovery so like an uninterruptible
power supply would be an example of that
you have your data center costs so
that's your rent cooling physical
security you have technical Personnel so
you're hiring people to do things for
you and so with capital expenses you
have to guess up for what you plan to
spend now let's look at operational
expenditure so operational expenditure
is the cost Associated when an
on-premises data has shifted that cost
to the service provider so here in this
case it's the cloud service provider and
the customer only has to be concerned
with non-physical costs so what are some
examples of Opex costs well leasing
software and customizing features
training employees and cloud services
paying for cloud support billing based
on the cloud metrics so compute usage
and storage usage and the advantage here
is that operational expenses you can try
a product or service without investing
equipment so we have flexibility of
investment and also from the previous
slide covering total cost of the
ownership we saw that we have a huge
reduction cost so those are two really
good reasons to use the cloud
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Cloud architecture
terminologies and these are very
important to help you conceptualize the
advantages of the cloud so we're going
to go through these terms and then we're
going to go through them again in more
detail in further slides so at the top
of our list we have availability and
this is your ability to ensure a service
remains available this is generally
known as being highly available or high
availability abbreviated to hot that's a
term you should know then we have
scalability so your ability to grow
rapidly or unimpeded then you have
elasticity so this is your ability to
shrink or grow to meet the demand you
have fault tolerance this is your
ability to prevent a failure then you
have Disaster Recovery this is your
ability to recover from a failure this
is generally known as being highly
durable or high durability so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the concept of
high availability so high availability
is the ability for your service to
remain available by ensuring there is no
single point of failure and or to ensure
a certain level of performance so here I
have a technical architectural diagram
that is describing High availability so
the idea behind this is that if you have
a server which runs your web application
if you were to run redundant versions of
your server if anything happened to a
single server traffic would always be
routed to those other servers and that
would allow your service to remain
available now having multiple servers is
great but what's even better is having
multiple servers in multiple data
centers because something could happen
to a data center it could become
unavailable because of the networking
issue so by being able to Route traffic
to those servers you're going to remain
highly available running a workload
across multiple availability zones and
availability zones is what Azure calls
their data centers and shares that if
one or two data center becomes
unavailable your service will remain
available it's very very common to run
at least three servers across three data
centers now how would you distribute the
traffic or manage the traffic to all
three well that's where an Azure load
balancer comes into play represented as
a green diamond with the arrows that is
the representation of a load balancer so
a load balancer allows you to evenly
distribute traffic to multiple servers
in one or more data centers and if a
data center or server becomes
unavailable so in healthy the load
balancer will route the traffic to only
available data centers with servers so
there you go that is high availability
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at the concept of high
scalability and this is your ability to
increase your capacity based on the
increasing demand of traffic memory and
computing power if you are a growing
company you're going to have to scale up
you're going to have to get bigger and
better servers but there are different
types of scaling so the first type of
scaling is vertical scaling this is the
most obvious one people are going to
think of and it's called scaling up what
we do is we just upgrade to bigger
servers we need bigger stronger and
faster computers for instance if your
server requires more processing power
vertical scaling would mean upgrading
the CPUs you can also vertically scale
the memory storage or network speed
there's another kind of scaling called
horizontal scaling and horizontal
scaling is described as scaling out what
you're doing is you're just adding
additional servers because we saw with
the high availability we have a load
balancer we can distribute traffic to
multiple servers and three servers can
equal the same thing as one big server
so horizontal scaling is when we add
more servers of the same size for
example if you are hosting an
application on a server and find that it
no longer has the capacity or
capabilities to handle traffic adding a
server may be your solution
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at the concept of high
elasticity and this is your ability to
automatically increase or decrease Your
Capacity based on the current demand of
traffic memory and computing power so
this sounds a lot like high scalability
but the key difference is that it's
automatic and you can decrease the
demand not just increase it so the way
we would do that is that we would have a
virtual machine or server and if we
needed more servers we would add more
servers and if we needed less servers we
would remove servers or servers that are
not being used and so this is going to
be accomplished using horizontal scaling
so when we say we're scaling out this
means we're adding more servers of the
same size when we're scaling in this
means we're removing servers of the same
size generally you're not going to use
vertical scaling for a high elasticity
this is because it's just extremely
difficult to vertically scale for
example if you have to increase your
storage drive and then you decrease it
you could potentially lose data so it's
not a good idea or even feasible to do
vertical scaling with high elasticity
now how would you accomplish a list City
on Azure well you'd use azure's VM scale
set so scale sets automatically increase
or decrease in the response to demand or
based on a defined schedule and then we
have SQL Server stretch database these
dynamically stretch warm and cold
transactional data from Microsoft SQL
Server 2016 to a Microsoft Azure it's
not something that we're going to cover
but it's generally the same concept of
what scale sets do so there you go
that's high elasticity
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at the concept of
being highly fault tolerant and this is
the ability for your service to ensure
there is no single point of failure
preventing the chance of failure so when
we looked at high availability we also
said that there was no point of failure
but when we really talk about that we're
really talking about being highly fault
tolerant because there's the word
failure in the word and that is what
being fault tolerant is so how do we
prevent failure well we use the concept
of failovers so failovers is when you
have a plan to shift traffic to a
redundant system in case a primary
system fails and so I have a Graphic
here that represents a primary database
failing over to a secondary database so
the idea is that we have a copy of our
production database and we're going to
call that a secondary system and every
time something is written to our primary
database it's going to be synced so it's
going to be sent over to our secondary
database so it's up to date with the
latest database and then if the primary
database happens to fail for whatever
reason whether it's Hardware or
otherwise it's going to detect that
there's something wrong with the prime
primary database and it's going to fail
over to the secondary database and the
secondary database is going to be
promoted to being the primary Database
The key thing to understand is that the
secondary database is on standby it's
not in actual use it's only in use when
the failover occurs so what would you
use in Azure to build out a highly fault
tolerance system that's where Azure
traffic manager comes into play so this
works at the DNS level the idea here is
that you can fail over from a primary
system at the DNS level to a standby
secondary system this is really great if
you have Regional failures you could
probably also use a load balancer but
this is the case that I'm showing here
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the concept of
high durability so this is your ability
to recover from a disaster and to
prevent the loss of data so solutions
that recover from a disaster is known as
Disaster Recovery Dr you can think of
durability as a measurement of how
healthy and resilient your data is you
want your data to be as safe and secure
when you retrieve it as it was on the
day you stored it so I'm just going to
ask you a few questions to help you
think about how to be highly durable so
one question would be do you have a
backup in place how fast can you restore
your backup does your backup still work
how do you ensure a current live data is
not corrupt data loss can happen through
human accident natural or man-made
disaster or even malicious action out of
your control whether you store data in
your home office or with a cloud
provider that data needs to be protected
as much as possible for many event that
could damage or destroy it you need to
ensure that you have the questions
listed to be answered with an
appropriate solution to ensure high
durability there are a variety of
services to implement high durability so
it's not just a single service so that
is the concept of high durability and
that is the full list of cloud
architecture terminology
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
so before we talk about Microsoft 365
let's talk about the evolution from
Office 365 to Microsoft 365. so Office
365 was designed to bring together its
existing online products to a
continually up-to-date cloud service it
combined the core productivity apps such
as word excel PowerPoint Outlook Etc and
the collaboration and communication
tools such as exchange SharePoint and
Skype for business Microsoft's Cloud
productivity Services have expanded much
beyond what most people think of his
office in recent years resulting in
Microsoft 365 therefore renaming Office
365 to Microsoft 365 reflects the
extension of features and benefits
beyond the core Office 365 products and
services Microsoft 365 includes
everything in Office 365 and more such
as Windows teams and other cloud-based
security and device management products
and services it's designed to help
people and businesses achieve more with
Innovative apps intelligent cloud
service is and world-class security
Microsoft 365 is a subscription service
that ensures you always have the most
up-to-date modern productivity and
collaboration tools you'll always have
access to the most up-to-date features
fixes and security upgrades as well as
technical assistance if you already have
an Office 365 subscription it
automatically becomes a Microsoft 365
subscription and no action is needed
from your end so that gives us a bit of
background of how Microsoft 365 came to
be
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Windows 365.
many of you are probably familiar with
Windows Windows is a well-known
operating system with the most recent
versions being Windows 10 and 11. so
what is Windows 365 Windows 365 isn't it
operating system and it isn't installed
on your computer in the same way that
Windows is it's a subscription service
for organizations that allows you to
create and run PCS remotely Windows 365
is referred to as a cloud PC this is
because it securely streams your
personalized Windows desktop apps
settings and content from the cloud to
any device a cloud PC is a virtualized
computer environment that allows you to
stream your Windows Experience from
Microsoft's Cloud to any device with a
cloud pc windows evolves from a
device-based operating system to hybrid
personalized Computing so Windows 365
has the following capabilities it's
simple to deploy and manage from a
single console it uses a local profile
that is stored directly on the cloud PC
you can easily set up and scale Cloud
PCS to fit your needs and securely
support changing Workforce needs and new
business scenarios it provides native
integration across Azure active
directory Microsoft Defender Microsoft
365 applications and Microsoft endpoint
manager and it's also dedicated to a
single user Windows 365 is available in
two subscription offerings Windows 365
business which is made specifically for
smaller organizations of up to 300 seats
who want ready to use cloud PCS with
simple management options Windows 365
Enterprises for larger organizations who
want unlimited seats for creating Cloud
PCS so that's windows 365.
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the main part
of the course Microsoft 365. so
Microsoft 365 is a cloud-based
subscription service that consists of an
integrated portfolio of products like
office apps teams Windows world-class
security and more it helps solve today's
challenges to productivity and secure
work from anywhere it helps you be more
productive from anywhere with the right
tools you can enable your team to
perform at their best with Cloud
technology to improve team collaboration
for many location Microsoft teams helps
you connect with colleagues through chat
voice and video it lets you create
content with built-in office apps and
use the power of artificial intelligence
to improve work you can use integrated
tools to simplify work and automate
manual processes with Microsoft Viva you
can build a culture that allows your
people to achieve their best from
anywhere and you can easily transition
from computer to mobile devices with
Innovative mobile apps enabling you to
stay productive on the go so with
Microsoft 365 you can secure your
organization with reliable technology G
it elevates and modernize your security
manage risk and meet compliance
standards on Microsoft's trusted Cloud
it ensures only the right users have
access with Azure active directory
multi-factor authentication and
biometric access like Windows hello with
Microsoft endpoint manager you can
deploy a seamless end-to-end management
solution and gain Insight across all
connected devices with Microsoft 365
Defender it protects your company
against sophisticated cyber attacks and
you can get real-time analysis of your
current security posture with Microsoft
secure score moving on to the cost
Effectiveness and efficientness factors
so you get one cost-effective solution
with Microsoft 365 you consolidate into
a single platform versus by numerous
platforms for multiple capabilities you
save out Automation and process
improvements through workflows
dashboards and AI it reduces your total
cost of Risk by enhancing your security
and compliance posture and 365 manages
hardware and software more efficiently
so it can focus on strategy it reduce
hard cost us like real estate and travel
through flexible work from anywhere you
can also access Microsoft 365 through
portal.office.com so that's the general
overview of Microsoft 365.
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft 365
apps so Microsoft 365 apps is a suite of
apps that help you stay connected and
complete your tasks these apps consist
of the office suite of applications such
as word excel PowerPoint OneNote Outlook
teams and more Microsoft 365 apps
provides the benefits of the cloud
giving you the flexibility to work from
anywhere at any time on any device
helping you be more productive so let's
go over the three key features of
Microsoft 365 apps Microsoft 365 apps
allow you to work across multiple
devices depending on your plan you can
install Microsoft 365 apps on up to five
PCS or Macs as well as five tablets iPad
windows or Android the apps that you
work with are always up to date you
won't have to spend time installing
updates or worrying about when new
features will be introduced you and your
co-workers will always be working with
the latest up-to-date features Microsoft
365 apps lets you work intelligently
through connected experiences it
includes intelligent features also
called connected experiences to help you
get work done faster and create amazing
content also in terms of subscriptions
Microsoft 365 apps are available in both
Microsoft 365 Apps for business and
Microsoft 365 apps for Enterprise
subscriptions so here we have a list of
some of the applications included in
Microsoft 365 apps we'll give a general
overview of what they do and for some
we'll cover in Greater detail later on
in the course Microsoft teams can help
you bring everyone together in one
location to meet chat call and
collaborate word can help you create
impressive documents and improve your
writing with built-in intelligent
features like Microsoft editor and
researcher Excel can help you simplify
complex data and create easy to read
spreadsheets and visualizations
PowerPoint can help you easily produce
polished presentations that stand out
with intelligent features like presenter
coach and PowerPoint designer Outlook
allows you to keep track of your email
calendar tasks and contacts all in one
in place OneNote can help you keep track
of your notes by organizing them into
tabs and subsections resulting in a
single digital notebook so that's the
overview of Microsoft 365 apps
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going over the Work
Management capabilities and tools in
Microsoft 365. the first one we'll be
talking about is Microsoft Project so
Microsoft Project is a powerful project
management tool designed for larger more
complex work tasks project for the web
is Microsoft's most recent offering for
cloud-based work and project management
it provides simple and Powerful Work
Management capabilities to meet most
needs and roles project managers and
team members can utilize project for the
web to plan and manage work that
requires Dynamic scheduling subtests and
or dependent tasks regardless of Team
size you can take on tasks of various
sizes from little projects to large
initiatives so now let's go over some of
the features of project so you can start
a project quickly and assign tasks and
schedules while keeping team members and
managers on the same page project
provides the smart scheduling engine
which will automatically update the
timeline saving you time and effort you
can utilize the easy to use views such
as grid views Camden style task boards
and timeline Gantt charts you can
integrate with Microsoft teams to
improve collaboration across the project
in power bi you can create attractive
interactive dashboards to see every
aspect of the project at a glance
finally it's extensible with other
platform apps and data because project
is built on the Power Platform so that's
Microsoft Project
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next Work Management tool in
Microsoft 365 we'll be talking about is
Microsoft planner so Microsoft planner
is a user-friendly collaborative task
management tool for planning managing
and completing task-based initiatives it
provides a simple and visual way for
teams to organize their work planner is
a web-based application that can be
accessed from anywhere and it also has a
mobile version for IOS and Android so
now let's go over some of the features
of Microsoft planner so you can create a
plan to give task-based teamwork
structure and to organize the activities
in your project you can assign and
manage tasks on a canvan board using
task cards and add those tasks to
buckets task cards provide various
information such as due dates status
priority checklists labels and file
attachments you can manage the
notifications you receive to stay on top
of deadlines Microsoft planner lets you
keep track of your team's progress with
colorful visual cues and built-in status
reporting you can utilize visuals like
the task board charts page page and
scheduled view summarize the status of
your entire plan and individual tasks
you can also integrate with teams by
adding a tasks by planner tab so that
lets you assign tasks with admissions in
Word Excel and PowerPoint and add your
plans to your Outlook calendar so that's
Microsoft planner
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft
bookings so Microsoft bookings is a
web-based appointment scheduling and
management system with Microsoft
bookings scheduling and managing
appointments is made easier it includes
a web-based booking calendar and
integrates with Microsoft Outlook to
optimize your staff's calendar and give
your customers the flexibility to book a
time that works best for them so now
let's go over some of the features of
Microsoft bookings so by using the
web-based business facing page you can
Define appointment types and details
manage employee schedules set business
hours services and pricing and customize
how appointments are scheduled you can
also allow extra time between
appointments for any pre or post
appointment tasks you can create a
booking page where your customers and
clients can make their own appointments
and reschedule them you can also share
the booking page with a direct link on
your Facebook page or by embedding the
link into your website Microsoft
bookings provides automatic appointment
notifications via email and SMS to
ensure that customers receive proper
confirmation stations and reminders you
can view your appointments access
customer lists and contact information
and make manual bookings on the go with
the business facing mobile app you can
also integrate with Microsoft teams or
Skype for business to support virtual
appointments and bookings calendar
management through the bookings app and
teams so that's the list of features for
Microsoft bookings
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about the last Work
Management tool in Microsoft 365 on the
list Microsoft Hadoop Microsoft to do is
an intelligent task management app that
makes it easy to plan and manage your
day it provides a smarter more personal
and intuitive way for people to stay
organized and make the most out of their
day to do is powered by Office 365
exchange online and can be integrated
with Outlook and planner Microsoft to do
is available on a variety of platforms
including iOS Android windows and the
web to do empowers you to complete the
most important tasks you need to get
done every day whether they are for work
school or at home so now let's look at
some of the features of Microsoft to do
Microsoft to do provides a daily to-do
list called my day that will help you
focus and complete your most important
tasks you can utilize Smart Suggestions
to add tasks upcoming or overdue tasks
you can get an overview of what you
accomplished yesterday and tasks you
didn't complete lists can be made for
any occasion and shared with others to
do lets you break down more complex
tasks into subtests you can separate
lists of tasks generated from flag dial
book emails you can also schedule
reminders and repeatable tasks and
finally you can view your assigned tasks
from planar into do so that's the list
of features for Microsoft to do
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about business
class email and calendar with Microsoft
Exchange Microsoft Exchange online is a
hosted messaging solution that delivers
the capabilities of Microsoft Exchange
Server as a cloud-based service it
allows users to access email calendar
contacts and tasks from PCS the web and
mobile devices all in one place it
integrates fully with all other
Microsoft 365 workloads making
Administration easy one thing you might
be wondering is what's the difference
between Microsoft Exchange online and
Outlook well exchange is a mail server
which means it's a dedicated Network
Resource Management program whereas
Outlook is an email client which means
it's a software program installed on
your desktop that is designed to send
and receive emails so let's go over some
of the features of Microsoft Exchange
online Microsoft 365 syncs your emails
calendars and contacts across all of
your devices ensuring that you are
always up to date no matter where you
are you can create your own custom
format add images and use your own
domain name based on where you live you
can create a public folder for shared
access to provide an easy way to collect
organize and share information with
other people in your work group or
organization you can share your calendar
in exchange online to allow businesses
to collaborate with other businesses and
to let users share their schedules with
others you can set up new users restore
deleted accounts and create custom
scripts and more exchange also is secure
it has built an anti-spam and
anti-malware protection customizable
anti-spam and anti-malware policies and
many more security features so that's
the list of features for Microsoft
Exchange online
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to create
a Microsoft account so the first thing
you want to do is to go to this link
here called account.microsoft.com and
this will take you to this page here and
if you don't already have a Microsoft
account you want to navigate to this
button here and click on create account
so this is the page where you create
your Microsoft account here is where
you'd enter in your email you want to
register with let's go with this one
example001 at gmail come
and it'll ask you to create a password
so let's enter that in here very quickly
you'll have to enter in the country
you're from as well as your date of
birth so the usual things for
registrations
you'll get a verification code for the
email you registered with and you'll
have to confirm it to complete the
process
I have the email account already open so
I can get the code here 8802 copy and
paste the code into the verification you
can choose to receive information tips
and offers about Microsoft products and
services if you're interested
looks like we have to go through this
puzzle to prove we're not a bot so we'll
go through this very quickly
okay great you've now created your
Microsoft account so once you have your
account created you can try Microsoft
365 for free or you can buy a
subscription some of you may already
have Microsoft 365 it could be provided
by your company or other sources
you can go to this link here called
microsoft.com en-ca Microsoft Dash 365
slash Microsoft dash
365-business dash standard dash one dash
month Dash trial to try Microsoft 365
for free for the purpose of the
demonstration we'll sign up for the
Microsoft 365 business standard trial
for one month first we need to provide
our email address so let's enter that in
here example 001 at gmail.com
then we need to set up our account so we
need to provide our name surname
business phone number company name
company size Etc it should be fine if
you don't have one or you may come up
with something
then we'll need to perform the
verification code process again enter in
the numbers you got from your phone
number
you can choose to create a new business
email later or create a new business
email with a Microsoft domain we'll need
to create a new business email with a
Microsoft domain
let's go with Andrew Brown at example
001 dot on microsoft.com
and enter in the password you want
this is important because this will be
how you'll sign in this is not your
email like example zero zero when a
gmail.com the next part is the payment
process so we'll need to enter in the
information required
you won't be charged at all if you
cancel before one month
after this process you'll need to log in
with the new business email we created
earlier so Andrew Brown an example zero
zero one dot on microsoft.com
enter in the password
so now we're currently at the Microsoft
365 admin Center you can install the
latest office apps here such as word
excel PowerPoint Outlook teams OneDrive
and so much more Microsoft 365 has a ton
of services and apps that'll improve
your productivity and collaboration
within your organization it has many
analytical capabilities and its security
is world class we'll be covering all
these services and features in Greater
detail throughout the entire course
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to create
a new Microsoft 365 user from within the
Microsoft 365 admin Center the first
thing you want to do is to open your web
browser and navigate to
admin.microsoft.com and log in by using
your administrator credentials on the
left hand navigation menu click on users
then active users this will provide the
list of available users on the main
screen to add a single user click on the
add a user button on the top of the page
underneath the active users label on the
setup the basics page fill in the first
name last name display name username and
domain for the new user also decide
which check boxes to check and more
specifically choose the following the
first one is automatically create a
password check this option if you need
the Microsoft 365 admin Center to
automatically allocate a new temporary
password to the new user the next one is
require this user to change their
password when they first sign in This is
highly recommended as you would normally
expect that the user changed the
temporary password which you initially
sent to a strong password word only they
will know the last one is send password
and email upon completion combined with
the previous checkbox this is the most
secure option since you would not have
to share the temporary password over any
other non-secure means enter the email
address to which the new password will
be set in the generated text box after
having filled in all required
information click on next to continue on
the assign product licenses page select
the user location and choose whether a
Microsoft 365 license will be assigned
to the user by ticking the appropriate
checkbox or if the user will be created
without a product license we'll be
providing the user with a Microsoft 365
business standard license there's also
an app section where you can select
specific applications that you want the
user to have access to for the Microsoft
365 business standard license there's
roughly 29 available once you're
satisfied with the settings click on
next to continue on the optional
settings page you can choose whether the
new user will have any additional
Microsoft 365 roles such as exchange
administrator Global administrator or
global Global reader for this example we
won't Grant the user admin access click
next to continue this will lead you to
the review and finish page fill in any
additional user profile information if
you wish to review all user information
and click finish adding your new user
should now appear in the Microsoft 365
admin Center active users home page
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to access
all the Microsoft 365 online apps we
won't be providing an overview of the
functionality offered by each app
because the course will provide a
detailed overview of all the important
ones for the exam the easiest way to
navigate to your Microsoft 365 online
apps is to go to the urlcultoffice.com
and sign in with your credentials then
on the top left corner click on the
dotted Square icon and click on all apps
this should provide the list of
Microsoft 365 apps you have available
according to your license in this case
these are the apps available for the
Microsoft 365 business standard license
alternatively you can view the apps in a
larger perspective by clicking on the
explore apps button or going to the URL
calledoffice.com apps you can see apps
here such as bookings calendar Excel
OneDrive Outlook planner and many more
that will meet your business needs
add-ins can be accessed as well by
clicking on the top right button here at
insert Microsoft 365 certified apps
which are listed in the Microsoft
appsource portal available at
appsource.microsoft.com the add-ins
integrate with Microsoft 365 apps to
extend the native functionality with
more granular and specialized features
so that's how you can access all the
M365 online apps
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft
teams and its core components and the
value it provides when it comes to
collaboration workloads so Microsoft
teams is your organization's core Center
for collaboration with a chat based
workplace to help everyone work more
productively it's an app for people and
teens to come together stay connected
and get things done across work home
school and on the go so the first
component of Microsoft teams we are
going to talk about are the teams and
channels so teams are a collection of
people content and tools surrounding
different projects and outcomes within
an organization it's designed to bring
together a group of people who work
closely to get things done teams can be
public and open to anyone within the
organization also a team has a limit of
up to 10 000 simultaneous members
channels are dedicated sections within a
team to keep conversations organized by
specific topics projects disciplines or
whatever works for your team it's a
place where users can discuss and get
Hands-On with work there are three types
of channels the first type of Channel or
standard channels this can be open to
all team members next we have private
channels which are for selected team
members the last type of channel are
shared channels this can select people
both inside and outside the team so the
next component of Microsoft teams we'll
be talking about is the chat and instant
messaging so chat and instant messaging
lets you work together without
cluttering up your email and keeping it
clear for important messages some of the
advantages of using chat and instant
messaging include it keeps the people
informed by chatting what unwinder in
groups it encourages open debate by
asking questions and encouraging open
discussion you can start a call or share
screens to get things done faster the
messages are sent in real time but it
doesn't disturb your co-workers work you
can use your mobile device to chat to
stay in touch no matter where you are
teams can be used to share useful files
and store everything in one place you
can host audio video and web conferences
and chat with colleagues from within and
outside your company
so another component of Microsoft teams
is called Microsoft teams phone
Microsoft team's phone is a secure
integrated calling service that combines
traditional and modern features it can
be used on your computer tablet mobile
device or desk phone to stay connected
with voice and video calling teams phone
has updated Cloud calling features like
voicemail transcription and group call
pickup to elevate your experience beyond
that of traditional calls with teams
phone you can seamlessly transition
calls from your home Wi-Fi to your
cellular service while on the go and
then back to your office Wi-Fi once you
arrive you can also start a call from
chat contact card Outlook or the calls
app to save time and reduce costs so
that's Microsoft teams phone and that
gives us an overview of the core
components of Microsoft teams and the
value it provides in collaboration
workloads
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going over some of the
collaborative apps we can use to extend
teams so a collaborative app is a
solution integrated or built into teams
that enables employees to work better
together using the tools they already
know apps for teams can be simple or
complex depending on your needs it could
be as simple as sending notifications to
channels or users or as complex as
multi-service apps incorporating
conversational Bots you could Implement
natural language processing or even
embedded web experiences some of the
ways that you can extend teams using
collaborative apps are how are bi and
teams can help your organization to
collaborate with data to achieve better
outcomes power apps can help you build
apps to add directly into teams by
creating a tab power automate can help
you automate tasks and processes all
within teens Dynamics 365 and teams
integration can provide high level
details of your customers ensuring that
you have useful contacts that are
prepared for customer interactions Tower
virtual agents allows you to create chat
Bots that can be integrated into teens
you could also integrate with with
third-party partners and services for
more capabilities within teams like
servicenow or Salesforce so those are
some of the ways you can use
collaborative apps to extend teams
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft
Power Platform so Microsoft Power
Platform is a line of business
intelligence app development and app
connectivity software applications
Microsoft Power Platform is composed of
four key products power apps power
automate power bi which stands for
business intelligence and powered
virtual agents and we'll be talking
about these four products in a bit more
detail in the next couple slides before
we talk about the four key products of
Power Platform we want to talk about the
cross-cutting features which enable
Microsoft Power Platform to be leveraged
to its full potential some of these are
AI Builder which lets users and
developers add AI capabilities to the
workflows and power apps they create in
use it adds intelligence to your
workflows and apps and predict outcomes
to help improve business performance
without writing code Microsoft dataverse
is a scalable data service and app
platform which lets users securely store
and manage data from multiple sources
and integrate that data in business
applications using a common data model
to ensure days and consistency to users
connectors enable you to connect apps
data and devices in the cloud there are
more than 600 connectors for Microsoft
Power Platform enabling all your data
and actions to connect cohesively so
let's start talking about the key
products of Power Platform starting with
power apps powerapps provides a rapid
low code development environment for
building custom apps for business needs
it has Services connectors and a
scalable data service and app platform
to allow simple integration and
interaction with existing data some of
the features of power apps include
enabling the creation of web and mobile
applications that run on all devices it
has an easy user experience for app
development with a simple interface so
that every business user or Pro
developer can build custom apps it
provides over 200 connectors to
integrate data and systems it enhances
productivity with pre-built AI scenarios
powerapps provides private and secure
submission of information so that's
powerapps the next product we'll be
talking about is power automate power
automate lets users create automated
workflows between applications and
services it helps automate repetitive
business processes such as communication
data Collections and decision approvals
the following is a list of power
automate features Tower automate allows
for the creation of Enterprise grade
process automation it provides a simple
interface allowing every level of user
to automate work tasks from beginners to
season developers it provides hundreds
of pre-built connectors power automate
provides AI Builder it can predict
outcomes to improve performance so
that's power automate the next product
is power bi which is a business
analytics service that delivers insights
for analyzing data it can share those
insights through data visualizations
which make up reports and dashboards to
enable fast informed decisions some of
the power bi features include it can
scale across an organization and has
built-in governance and security
allowing businesses to focus on using
data more than managing it it takes
company data and lets you to display it
in the most user-friendly way possible
power bi offers a wide range of detailed
and attractive visualizations as you can
see on the image on the right it can
access vast volumes of data from
multiple sources it helps to gather
analyze publish and share Excel business
data power bi also enables you to
perform real-time stream analytics so
that's power bi finally the last product
we'll be talking about is power virtual
agents power virtual agents enables
anyone to create powerful chat Bots
using a guided no code graphical
interface without the need for data
scientists or developers it minimizes
the it effort required to deploy and
maintain a custom Solution by empowering
subject matter experts to build and
maintain their own conversational
Solutions some of the power virtual
agents features include users can enable
chat Bots to perform in action by simply
calling a power automate flow close help
users automate activities or call
back-end systems reduce costs by easily
automating common inquiries and freeing
human agent time to deal with more
complex issues users can utilize
existing flows that have been created in
their powerapps environment improve
customer satisfaction by allowing
customers to sell help and resolve
issues quickly 24 7 using Rich
personalized bot conversations so that's
the overview of Power Platform and its
key products
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about what Yammer
is and how Yammer helps communities
connect and grow Yammer is a secure
Enterprise social network internal to an
organization the Amber connects and
engages leaders and co-workers from any
location to share ideas co-create
culture coordinate on strategy and
innovate it was designed to help you
connect with people across your
organization who you might not work with
directly Yammer helps facilitate
Community collaboration and idea sharing
for your organization you can access
yabra through your browser or install it
on your desktop or mobile device the
average supports both internal and
external networks to help users
communicate and collaborate an internal
network is restricted to users inside
the organization whereas an external
network is open to users outside the
organization's domain users and external
networks must be invited
so now we'll be going over some of the
details on how Yammer helps connect
leaders and employees to build
communities share knowledge and engage
everyone Yammer helps facilitate leader
engagement it helps align people toward
a shared vision and objectives to drive
organizational change and it Fosters
two-way dialogue between employees and
Leaders with a leadership Community he
ever modernizes employee communication
it helps keep everyone informed and
engaged across web and mobile and it
shares news and announcements that reach
users as interactive discussions in
Microsoft teams and Outlook the Aver
helps engage your employees to ensure
that every voice within the organization
is heard and it provides communities for
employees to connect share and build
relationships he ever encourages
knowledge sharing so you can share
knowledge best practices ideas and
feedback across the organization you can
also use questions and answers to gain
Solutions highlight the best answers and
up the replies finally the Amber Powers
communities in Microsoft 365 you can
engage in fully interactive discussions
without leaving your Outlook inbox and
bring the power of communities to
SharePoint with the Yammer conversations
web part so that's the general overview
of Yammer and how it can be used to help
communities connect and grow
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft
Viva and its core employee experience
capabilities so Microsoft Viva is an
employee experience platform that
empowers people and teens to be their
best from anywhere Viva brings together
Communications insights Knowledge
Learning and resources within the flow
of everyday work and collaboration it's
experience through Microsoft teams and
other Microsoft 365 apps that people use
every day there are four different
modules for viva viva connections which
is used to stay engaged and informed
Viva insights which helps balance
productivity and well-being Viva topics
which is used to connect to knowledge
and experts and finally Viva learning
which helps make learning a natural part
of your day so we'll now be exploring
each module in Greater detail starting
with Viva connections so Viva
connections was created to keep everyone
in the workforce connected to each other
and you might be wondering well we have
so many tools for employee
Communications and engagement in
Microsoft 365 like SharePoint Yammer to
teams and stream why would we need
another one well what makes Viva
connections unique is that it combines
all of these capabilities into a company
branded app it's a hub for personalized
news Communications tasks people and
resources for employees leaders can
communicate and engage their employees
while employees can access all of the
tools and resources they require in one
location so Viva connections provides
additional functionality through three
main components which are listed below
first we have the dashboard the
dashboard is your employees digital tool
set it brings together the tools and
resources your employees need enabling
quick and easy access whether they are
in the office or in the field next is
the feed the feed delivers updates to
the right people at the right time with
powerful targeting and scheduling
capabilities and then we have resources
the resources experience enables a way
to navigate across platforms so that's
Viva connections the next module we'll
be talking about is Viva insights so
Viva insights provides privacy protected
insights and actionable recommendations
that help everyone in the organization
station work smarter and Achieve balance
it uses quantitative and qualitative
data to empower individuals managers and
leaders to improve organizational
productivity and well-being so Viva
insights categorizes their analytical
insights based on personal insights
manager insights and organizational
insights the first one we'll talk about
is personal insights as we mentioned
before individuals can gain valuable
insights to improve work patterns
through actionable recommendations from
the personalized Viva insights app in
teams for example prepare for the day
with a briefing email protect time for
Focus work and mindfully disconnect
after hours so we'll go over some of the
benefits it provides personal well-being
through this experience you could access
this home page to tap into moments of
self-reflection gratitude and breathing
breaks stay connected this experience
intelligently surfaces prior
Communications that might require
follow-up AI based task suggestions and
meeting assistance make it seamless to
schedule one one second to catch up with
important people in your network protect
time this experience audience makes it
easy to schedule focused time to work
uninterrupted during the day before it
fills up with meetings Daily Briefing
the daily briefing email from viva
automatically appears in your inbox near
the start of the day the email provides
recommendations of documents for you to
review prior to the day's meetings
effective meetings meeting organizers
will be able to view personalized
insights and suggestions to help improve
their meeting habits and feedback for
their meetings so the next analytical
Insider manager insights manager
insights can help you build a healthy
and effective team managers can easily
understand current team norms and take
action to achieve positive change with
the Viva insights tool in teams let's
look at the three key features under the
my team tab for managers first we have
nudges you can use intelligent nudges or
reminders help you stay connected with
your team it helps you keep up with
managerial demands like scheduling one
one second in responding to requests and
emails and document mentions recognize
strengths and accomplishments through
send praise to increase engagement in
morale next are the reflective insights
these are insights that can help help
influence your team culture this can
help identify personal work patterns and
behaviors that may be impacting team
stress and feelings of burnout in
Outlook you can gain insights through
the briefing and digest emails lastly we
have action plans this is where we can
create action plans to help develop
positive team standards hit prioritize
team well-being by promoting healthy
norms and boundaries like setting shared
recurring no meeting days or quiet hours
for focused and uninterrupted work next
we have Viva insights organizational
insights so Viva insights provide
organizational views to senior Business
Leaders CEOs business unit leaders and
other department heads these experiences
show leaders in aggregated view of work
and collaboration patterns across their
organizations let's look at how the
visual insights in the my organization
tab can benefit your company
organizational resilience it helps
enable work-life balance Provide
one-to-one support connect across
boundaries and cohesion within teams
Employee Engagement it can promote
coaching and development protect
employee capacity Drive of employee
empowerment and cohesion within teams
improve agility it helps organize better
meetings and connect across boundaries
effective managers this lets us optimize
manager meetings protect manager
capacity promote coaching and
development Empower employees and Foster
connectivity operational effectiveness
this can free up capacity improve
meeting quality keep employees engaged
and protect time to get work done
transform meeting culture this helps us
optimize Meeting hours examine recurring
meetings and promote healthy meeting
habits so that's the overview of Viva
insights and its analytical capabilities
the third module we'll be talking about
is Viva topics Viva topics focuses on
knowledge and expertise it uses
artificial intelligence to identify
knowledge and experts and then organizes
them into shared topics Viva topics
helps many businesses in addressing a
critical business issue which is
providing information to users when they
need it for example new employee hires
need to learn much new information
quickly at encounter terms they know
nothing about when reading through
company information in Viva topics
brings knowledge to your users in the
Microsoft 365 apps they use every day so
AI automatically creates a topic page
for each topic the topic page gives you
more details including definitions
relevant people and resources from
across Microsoft 365 and external
sources like servicenow these topic
pages are surfaced as topic cards write
in apps like office SharePoint and
Microsoft teams the topics are displayed
to users through topics highlighted on
SharePoint Pages topic answers and
search results search and office
applications topic Center home page so
that's the overview of Viva topics the
last module we'll be talking about is
Viva learning Viva learning is a
centralized Learning Hub in Microsoft
teams that allows you to easily
integrate learning and building skills
into your day in Viva learning your team
can discover share recommend and learn
from content libraries provided by both
your company and partners Viva learning
Aggregates content from LinkedIn
learning Microsoft learn third-party
training content and internal content of
your own all in one place so while
providing AI aggregation and
recommendations it also allows managers
to assign track and report on training
within and across multiple teams there
are three main views in the Viva
learning app tone which lets you
discover new content trending content
and browse learning content libraries by
alerting which allows you to access your
recommendations and assignments as well
as bookmarked recently viewed and
completed courses and manage which helps
you track the progress of
recommendations that you made so that's
Viva learning and I know that was quite
a bit to take in but we've now covered
all of Microsoft viva's four modules
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about SharePoint
and how it helps promote collaboration
so SharePoint is a cloud-based service
that allows companies to share and
manage content knowledge and
applications in order to improve
teamwork you can find information
quickly and seamlessly collaborate both
inside and outside the company it's a
rich collaboration tool for building
websites publishing content and storing
files some of the features that
SharePoint include are building sites
and Pages document libraries and lists
sharing important visuals news and
updates with a team or more broadly you
can search and discover sites files
people and news from across their
organization SharePoint helps manage
their business processes with flows
forms and lists you can sync and store
their files in the cloud so anyone can
securely work with them you can catch up
on News on the go with the SharePoint
mobile app SharePoint also provides
three main types of sites team sites or
collaboration sites to connect you and
your team to share content and resources
communication sites are designed to
Broad cast information to other teams or
to an entire organization Hub sites are
used to organize families of Team sites
and communication sites together so
that's SharePoint and all the features
it provides to help promote
collaboration
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about OneDrive and
its collaboration features so OneDrive
is a Microsoft 365 service that allows
users to access share and collaborate
files from anywhere OneDrive allows
users to View files in a browser share
and search content and sync that content
so they can access it offline you can
work with others inside or outside your
organization and terminate sharing
whenever you want OneDrive also empowers
your organization to control secure and
retain that content when necessary so
let's go over some of the key features
of OneDrive that help promote
collaboration users can easily store
access and discover individual and
shared work files in Microsoft 365
including Microsoft teams from any
device OneDrive provides seamless
collaboration with files it helps users
work faster and smarter with people
inside or outside your organization
users can create view edit and share
files on the go with the OneDrive mobile
app OneDrive provides Enterprise grade
security and protection for files
enabling you to meet some of the
strictest compliance requirements out
there you can also easily recover files
from accidental deletions or malicious
attacks so that's one drive and the key
features to promote collaboration
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft
stream on SharePoint so Microsoft stream
is an Enterprise video service where
people in your organization can upload
View and share videos securely you can
share recordings of classes meetings
presentations training sessions or other
videos that help your team's
collaboration
so the new version of stream Builds on
sharepoint's Rich content management
features and uses Microsoft graphs
intelligence to enhance videos across
Microsoft 365. the earlier version is
known as Microsoft stream classic
SharePoint Powers file experiences for
Microsoft teams OneDrive Yammer and
Outlook it provides intelligent video
experiences powered by stream across
this week it also provides management of
video that leverages the power of
SharePoint content services for
permission sharing compliance governance
and customizable portal experiences so
that's the general overview of Microsoft
stream and how it can be helpful to your
team's collaboration
thank you
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Microsoft
endpoint manager also known as mem so
your organization probably has Android
and iOS mobile phones Windows and Mac OS
PCS and custom devices that your
employees or users bring to work but how
can we configure or support all these
types of devices especially with your
organization well Microsoft 365 provides
the tools and services you need to
manage all of these devices through
Microsoft endpoint manager Microsoft
endpoint manager is a secure and
intelligent management solution that
improves productivity and collaboration
with the familiar experiences users
expect it provides it with the
flexibility to support diverse scenarios
for both bring your own device and
corporate owned devices and point
manager also helps you solve the
challenge of device management in
today's mobile and remote work
environment so Microsoft and point
manager includes the following service
and capabilities Microsoft InTune InTune
is a 100 cloud-based mobile device
management and mobile application
management provider for your apps and
devices configuration manager
configuration manager is an on-premises
management solution to manage desktops
servers and laptops that are on your
network or internet-based tow management
toe management combines your existing
on-premises configuration manager
investment with the cloud using InTune
and other Microsoft 365 cloud services
desktop analytics desktop analytics is a
cloud-based service that integrates with
configuration manager Windows autopilot
Windows autopilot sets up and
pre-configures new devices getting them
ready for use Azure ID which stands for
Azure active directory Azure ID is used
by endpoint manager for identity of
devices users groups and multi-factor
authentication and point manager admin
Center this admin Center is a One-Stop
website to create policies and manage
your devices these services are part of
the Microsoft 365 stack to help secure
access protect data and manage risk so
that's the overview of Microsoft
endpoint manager
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about Azure virtual
desktop also known as avd so Azure
virtual desktop on Microsoft Azure is a
modern and secure desktop and app
virtualization service that runs on the
cloud Azure virtual desktop works across
devices like Windows Mac iOS Android and
Linux with apps that you can use to
access remote desktops and apps you can
use most modern browsers to access Azure
virtual desktop hosted experiences Azure
virtual desktop is optimized for
flexibility with flexible
consumption-based pricing an example of
when Azure virtual desktop might be used
is when security is a concern because
all the data is saved on the server and
cannot be left on the device of a user
so Azure virtual desktop has the
following capabilities you can set up a
multi-session Windows client deployment
that delivers a full windows experience
with scalability there's seamless
integration with Microsoft 365 apps for
Enterprise and Microsoft teens it
provides reduced costs by using eligible
windows or Microsoft 365 live instances
to access Windows Virtual desktop and
pay only for what you use Azure virtual
desktop helps keep your team running
during outages by leveraging built-in
Azure site recovery and Azure backup
Technologies it manages the virtual
desktop infrastructure for you so you
can focus on users apps and Os images
instead of hardware and maintenance it
also uses FS logic's profile container
technology so that's Azure virtual
desktop and the key capabilities it
provides
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about the
deployment and release models for
Windows as a service also known as Ys so
Windows client is a comprehensive
desktop operating system that allows you
to work efficiently and securely whereas
Windows as a Services Microsoft strategy
of deploying updating and servicing the
Windows operating system the windows as
a service model is designed to make life
simpler for both users and it
professionals Microsoft Now updates
windows on a regular basis rather than
launching a new version every three to
five years as it has done with previous
versions of the operating system with
Windows client there are two release
types feature updates and quality
updates feature updates are scheduled
typically twice a year in March and
September they include new
functionalities for the operating system
quality updates or monthly cumulative
updates they contain security patches
and other changes to make the operating
system more reliable next we'll be
talking about servicing channels so
servicing channels are the first way to
separate users into deployment groups
for feature in quality updates there are
three servicing channels each Channel
each provides different levels of
flexibility for when these updates are
delivered to client computers the first
servicing channel is the windows Insider
program which allows businesses to test
and provide feedback on features that
will be released in the next feature
update these features will be delivered
as soon as possible during the
development cycle through a process
called flighting the general
availability Channel provides new
functionality with feature update
releases annually this model is ideal
for pilot deployments testing of feature
updates and users such as developers who
need to work with the latest features
the last servicing channel is the
long-term servicing Channel which is
designed for specialist devices that
don't run office apps like medical
equipment or ATMs this channel receives
new features every two or three years so
that's the servicing channels now we'll
be talking about the deployment rings so
deployment rings are a deployment method
used to separate devices into a
deployment timeline they are changes
that are rolled out in phases to
specific groups of users or computers
panty risks or development difficulties
associated with Windows updates are
reduced by this gradual controlled and
tested deployment each ring represents a
group of users or devices that receive a
particular update together so a common
ring structure uses three deployment
groups preview is for Planning and
Development the purpose of the preview
ring is to evaluate the new features of
the update limited is for pilot and
validation the purpose of the limited
ring is to validate the update on
representative devices across the
network broad is for wide deployment
once the device is in the limited ring
have had a sufficient stabilization
period it's time for broad deployment
across the network so that's Windows as
a service and all the deployment and
release models that it has load and
deploy Microsoft 365 apps to your client
computers so this method uses the ODT to
manage your deployment and the office
customization tool to create a
cloud-based configuration file that
specifies the Microsoft 365 apps that
are installed the next method is to
deploy from a local source with the
office deployment tool with this method
you may manage your deployment with the
ODT and download and deploy office from
a local Source on your network the last
method is to self-install from the cloud
which is probably the easiest one to
perform you manage your deployment from
the office portal and have your users
install office on their client devices
directly from the portal so those are
the four different methods to deploy
Microsoft 365 apps one of the benefits
of Microsoft 365 apps is that Microsoft
provides new and updated features for
office apps regularly Microsoft provides
you with something called update
channels these allow you to manage how
frequently new feature updates are sent
to your company here are the three
primary update channels for Microsoft
365 apps the first one is current
Channel which receives feature updates
at least once a month but there's no
exact set schedule update this channel
also receives security and non-security
updates around two or three times a
month Microsoft recommends this channel
because it provides users with the
newest office features as soon as
they're ready the next update channel is
monthly Enterprise Channel which
receives feature updates once a month
this monthly update can include feature
security and non-security Updates this
provides users with new office features
once a month on a predictable release
schedule and then we have semi-annual
Enterprise Channel which receives
feature updates every six months this
update can include feature security and
non-security Updates this is only for
select devices in your company that need
extensive testing before rolling out new
office features Microsoft also provides
each update Channel with two other types
of updates that are released on the
second Tuesday of every month there are
security updates such as updates that
help keep office protected from
potential malicious attacks and
non-security updates also known as
quality updates are updates that provide
stability or performance improvements
for office so that's the Microsoft 365
apps update channels types
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to deploy
Office 365 using the office
customization tool the first thing you
want to do is to go to Google and search
for office deployment tool and you want
to go to the link where it says office
deployment tool Microsoft 365 It's
usually the first one that shows up and
click on it once you click on it it'll
take you to the Microsoft 365 office
deployment tool page where you can
download the office deployment tool so
you want to click on download and you
can save this to any folder you prefer
but for this demonstration I'll place it
on the desktop okay the next thing you
want to do is to go to the URL called
config.office.com so you can access the
office customization tool alternatively
you can also access this through your
Microsoft 365 admin Center in your all
admin Center Page and by navigating to
office configuration
once you are at the office configuration
page you'll want to click on go to
office customization tool the next step
is to click on create this is where you
can customize how you want to deploy
your office 365. for architecture you
can choose 32-bit or 64-bit depending on
your system settings for this example
we'll select 64-bit for the type of
office suite we have a lot of options
such as Microsoft 365 apps for
Enterprise Microsoft 365 apps for
Business Office ltsc Professional Plus
2021 and many more for this example
we'll select the Microsoft 365 Apps for
business we're not interested in Vizio
so we'll select none for this we're not
interested in Project products we'll
select none for this and we don't need
any additional products
for the type of update Channel we'll go
with current Channel because it's
recommended and it provides users with
the newest office features as soon as
they are ready we'll select latest for
the type of version for the app sections
you can select which apps you want to
include or exclude we can leave this as
the default selections for the languages
we'll select English for the primary
language we won't be needed any
additional language tools or packages
for the installation options we can
choose from Office content delivery
Network local Source or Microsoft
endpoint configuration manger we can
leave this as office content delivery
Network in the default settings for the
update and upgrade options we can also
leave these as the default settings
for the licensing and activation section
we won't need to make any changes here
in the general section it's okay to
leave this blank it's not mandatory to
provide your organization name and
description unless your company requests
it for the application preferences we
don't really need to select anything
here either so you can scroll down and
click on finish
we'll give this configuration file a
simple name called configuration after
reviewing all of the configuration
settings you can click on download
you'll need to specify the format you
want as the user's default you can keep
the current settings choose office open
XML formats or Open document format for
this example we'll select keep current
settings click ok then click on download
again
save the XML document on the folder you
prefer or the same folder where you
downloaded the office deployment tool
earlier so now on our desktop we have
two files the office deployment tool and
the configuration XML file we will need
to create a new folder called Microsoft
apps for business or you can name it
office for short but you'll need to
remember this name for the next steps
we'll cut and paste the office
deployment tool and the office
configuration file in the Microsoft apps
for business folder we created
double-click on the office configuration
tool file
and select the box and click continue
select the folder Microsoft apps for
business and click OK this will extract
all the files to install Microsoft apps
for business into the folder the next
step is to move the Microsoft apps for
business folder into the local C drive
then you'll need to open up command
prompt as administrator you'll need to
run a few simple commands to complete
this process some of you should be
familiar with these
enter in c d c colon backslash Microsoft
apps for business or the name of the
folder you created this changes
directory to the Microsoft apps for
business folder then you run setup dot
exe slash configure configuration.xml
and this should install office or
Microsoft apps for business based on
your configuration file you created this
can take a while so you'll need to wait
for it to complete downloading and
installing after this is done you have
successfully installed office on your
computer
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be taking a look at the
analytics capabilities of Microsoft
workplace analytics so Microsoft
workplace analytics provides Rich
actionable insights into your
organization's communication and
collaboration Trends to help you make
more effective business decisions it
creates analysis about how your
organization spends its time the Waze
people Network and the effectiveness of
team collaboration just a quick note as
of recording this video workplace
analytics is becoming or is already part
of Microsoft Viva so let's look at some
of the main features of workplace
analytics with the workplace analytics
features you can see business outcomes
in their related research-based
behavioral insights that show how things
get done in your company use the explore
the stats explore in power bi and plans
options for more in-depth analysis
specific to your organization's data use
the templates and queries in the query
designer to jump start your analysis and
customize them for a more focused or
in-depth analysis analyze a specific
business process with the business
process analysis feature compare tricks
between groups with the peer analysis
feature and you can select targeted
change plans to improve focus
collaboration well-being and sales
success so that's workplace Analytics
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about the
analytical capabilities of my analytics
so my analytics is an application
designed to help employees and their
managers gain insight into how workers
spend their time with the goal of
optimizing tasks and making them more
efficient the application can track data
such as time spent in meetings Outlook
emails productivity and time spent
working late my analytics is also part
of Microsoft Viva so Microsoft organizes
these tasks into categories such as
Meeting hours email hours Focus hours
after hours work who is in a user's
Network and a basic time overview the
time overview can be used to provide a
quick overview of how a user is spending
their time the network section focuses
on analyzing who a user collaborates
with meetings will allow users to see
their time spent in meetings and how
they manage that time email will show
users how much time they spend emailing
others Focus hours are time spent
working outside of meetings minimum at
least two hours of time outside of
meetings and after hours is Microsoft's
way of stating how much time a user
spends working after their official work
day also my analytics and insights by my
analytics service plans are included
with the Microsoft 365 E5 plan so that's
my analytics and its key analytical
features
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about the
capabilities of the Microsoft 365 admin
Center in Microsoft 365 user portal so
the definition of Microsoft 365 admin
Center is very clear it's designed for
its professionals and administrators to
manage the organization's Microsoft 365
subscription the admin Center allows you
to perform a variety of tasks including
managing users checking reports and much
more the following list describes some
of the main tasks that are done in the
admin Center manage users by adding
deleting or restoring users manage
licenses by adding and removing license
manage a Microsoft 365 Group by creating
a group deleting a group and editing the
name or description manage billing view
or create service requests manage global
settings for apps view activity reports
and view service health so that's the
general overview of the Microsoft 365
admin Center next let's talk about the
Microsoft 365 user portal so the
Microsoft 365 user portal is designed
for users to access their email calendar
and documents through Microsoft 365 apps
like office teams Outlook and more users
can sign in with their email account and
password through
www.office.com only the apps for which
the user has a license will be shown the
portal allows you to quickly and easily
View and edit files that are saved in
OneDrive now let's talk about the
reports in the Microsoft 365 admin
Center so the Microsoft 365 admin Center
has reports that can help gather Insight
security and how employees are utilizing
Microsoft 365 products and services to
access these types of reports you must
have administrator permissions to access
the admin Center go to
admin.microsoft.com and sign in with
your admin account the following list
describes the two types of reports
available in the admin Center first we
have the productivity score this type of
report measures the work done in your
company to the work done in similar
companies it provides metrics and
insights and recommended actions you can
take to help your organization use
Microsoft 365 products and services
efficiently then we have usage you can
view these reports to understand how
people in your organization are using
the products and services you can go
further into each product report to get
more detailed insights about the
activities within each product so here
we have an image of the Microsoft 365
admin Center at the reports section
displaying the productivity score here
we can see the organization score which
is currently at one percent or three out
of 400 points it provides a summary for
section of the people's experiences and
categories such as Communication in
meetings it will also provide
suggestions to improve in these areas
and so on next we'll be talking about
reports and other admin centers so the
Microsoft 365 admin Center also gives
you access to other admin centers for
specific products and services such as
exchange teams and more the following
list describes some of the other admin
centers and the reports available first
we have Azure active directory the
reports available here provide a
comprehensive view of activity in your
environment then we have employ manager
Microsoft InTune reporting allows you to
proactively monitor the health and
activity of endpoints across your
organization next we have exchange view
reports of email flow within your
organization and mailbox migration
batches created for your organization
there's security and compliance view
reports about security Trends and track
the protection of your identities data
devices apps and infrastructure then we
have SharePoint the reports available
are about data access governance and
help you maintain the security and
compliance of your data in SharePoint
and we also have teams user activity and
device usage reports are available so
you can gain insights into the Microsoft
teams activity in your organization so
here we have an image of the Microsoft
365 admin Center at the all admin
centers section as we mentioned before
we can see that there's a variety of
admin centers listed such as Azure
active directory Azure TP compliance and
point manager exchange and so on they
also provide a brief description on what
you can configure and manage so that's
Microsoft 365 admin Center and the
different types of reports it provides
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to access
all the Microsoft 365 admin centers
we'll also provide a brief overview of
the functionality available in each
admin Center Microsoft 365 provides the
following admin centers we have the
Microsoft 365 main admin Center the main
admin Center allows you to manage most
aspects of Microsoft 365 Administration
including users teams and groups roles
resources billing support settings
reports and health monitoring the main
admin Center can be reached at
admin.microsoft.com let's navigate to
the all admin centers page to view the
full list of admin centers first we have
Azure active directory Azure active
directory allows you to control identity
and access management in Microsoft 365.
you can enable multi-factor
authentication self-service password
reset and edit company branding among
other available functions the Azure
active directory admin Center can be
reached at a ddotportal azure.com next
we have the Microsoft you compliance
portal which covers an important part in
the exam you can use the Microsoft
purview compliance portal to meet your
compliance and privacy goals you will
find Integrated Solutions which assist
you in protecting sensitive information
manage data life cycles reduce Insider
risks Safeguard personal data among
other features the Microsoft purview
admin Center can be reached at
compliance.microsoft.com next we have
exchange online The Exchange online
admin portal allows us MTP
administrators to manage Advanced email
settings such as quarantine encryption
and mail flow rules among other
available features The Exchange online
admin Center can be reached at
admin.exchange.microsoft.com next we
have office configuration this admin
Center allows you to manage configure
and monitor deployment of Microsoft 365
apps for your organization the office
configuration portal allows you to
graphically create Office 365 app
configuration files XML to be used as
input in the office deployment tool
which can automate Office 365
deployments and upgrades the office
configuration admin Center can be
reached at
config.office.com we have power apps you
can use the Power Platform admin Center
to manage activity licenses and policies
for user generated power apps which can
connect to your data and work across web
and mobile power automate manage the
automation of repetitive and
time-consuming tasks in the Power
Platform admin Center where you can set
up connections to web services files or
cloud-based data and put them to work
both the powerapps and power automate
admin Center can be reached at
admin.powerplatform dot microsoft.com
next we have search and intelligence
manage Microsoft search settings
including services and content that are
available for people in your
organization make finding internal tools
documents and people just as easy as
searching the web and Bing let's take a
look at security so the security portal
is now renamed to Microsoft 365 Defender
admin Center use the Microsoft 365
Defender admin Center for visibility
into threats to your network and your
security posture respond to incidents
proactively hunt for threats track your
assets and deploy policies to secure
your identities devices Office 365
workspaces apps among other features the
Microsoft 365 Defender admin Center can
be reached at
security.microsoft.com next we have
SharePoint online the SharePoint online
admin Center allows you to manage sites
sharing policies storage and all other
available features of SharePoint online
in OneDrive for business you could also
use this admin Center to streamline your
data migration to SharePoint online
sites in OneDrive for business the
SharePoint online admin Center can be
reached a tenant name Dash admin dot
sharepoint.com next we have stream use
the Microsoft stream admin Center to
manage video upload settings and
organize your corporate video portal the
stream admin Center can be reached at
web.microsoftstream.com
admin we have teams you can use the
Microsoft team James admin Center to
configure presence messaging
conferencing and external communication
options for your users as well as any
kind of Microsoft teams policy which can
be applied to your organization and to
your teams and groups the team's admin
Center can be reached at
admin.teams.microsoft.com finally we
have Yammer this admin Center allows you
to manage your Yammer social network set
a usage policy control external network
settings and enable features like
translation the Yammer admin Center can
be reached at yaber.com
tenantbusinessname slash admin there are
more admin centers in total but these
are the ones available for the specific
Microsoft 365 business standard license
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll begin covering the security
concepts of Microsoft 365 starting with
the zero trust methodologies or the zero
trust model in particular this is super
important because it really lays the
foundation of the way we should be
thinking about all the security that
we're going to be doing within Microsoft
365 Azure or in any cloud service
provider because the zero trust model is
really what is being adopted today and
we'll talk about why that is so the zero
trust model operates on the principles
of trust no one and verify everything so
nowadays you can potentially encounter
malicious actors and they're able to
bypass conventional access controls this
demonstrates that traditional security
measures are no longer sufficient we
need to come up with a new way to
protect ourselves and so that's where
Microsoft has come up with their version
of a zero trust model called the
Microsoft zero trust model and this is
based on three principles and six
foundational pillars so in the three
principles we have verify explicitly
least privileged access and assume
breach for the six found foundational
pillars we have identities and endpoints
an easier way of thinking about
endpoints is just thinking of them as
devices then we have apps data
infrastructure and networks and I would
say that if you wanted to put an
emphasis on anything it's going to be
identities because when an identity
attempts to access a resource it must be
verified with strong authentication and
follow these privileged access
principles the zero trust model is not
unique to Microsoft gcp has its own zero
trust model AWS has its own zero trust
model but the one here is just going to
really work for Microsoft so let's go in
more detail on the three principles that
are in the Microsoft zero trust model
the first principle is verify explicitly
and so this always authenticates and
authorizes based on all the available
data points including user identity
location device service or workload data
classification and anomalies the next
principle is least privileged access so
you limit user access with just in time
and just enough access risk-based
adaptive policies and data protection to
protect both data and productivity then
we have assumed breach so we need to
minimize blast radius and axis should be
segmented by Network user device and
application we must also verify
end-to-end encryption and use analytics
to gain visibility Drive threat
detection and improve security so that's
Microsoft's version of the zero trust
model and the three guiding principles
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we'll be talking about the six
foundational pillars for the Microsoft
zero trust model in Greater detail
starting with the most important one so
identities verifies and secures each
identity with strong authentication
across your entire digital estate for
each of these pillars we're going to
talk about some of the related Services
I'm not going to describe too much of
what they do because we're definitely
going to be covering the important ones
in this course in great detail but I
want you to get some exposure so you see
all these names over and over again so
the first one is identity access and
management or I am the next one is azure
active directory and this one gets a lot
of attention due to all its identity and
access management capabilities we have
single site on multi-factor
authentication or MFA passwordless
authentication which is a subset of MFA
risk-based policies and we have identity
secure score and you'll see a few
different types of secure score like
Microsoft secure score and compliance
score in this course so it's something
that's very useful throughout Microsoft
365 and azure measure next we have
endpoints and it's easy to think of
these as devices because their endpoints
are used to gain visibility into devices
accessing the network ensuring
compliance and health status before
granting access the endpoint is what
grants access for this for this we have
Azure ID device manager to register our
devices with our identity provider
generally the controls underneath which
is the mobile device management and
mobile application management is managed
by Microsoft InTune and this service is
now actually a part of Microsoft
endpoint manager and if we want to get
protection around our endpoints then we
have Microsoft Defender for endpoint but
we have Defender for a lot features in
Microsoft and you'll see that soon
enough then you have dlps data loss
prevention policies so that we do not
lose our data so that it does not get
disclosed and we can keep our sensitive
data protected so for apps we have
discovered Shadow I.T so ensure
appropriate in-app permissions gate
access based on real-time analytics and
monitor control user actions so for this
we have policy-based access controls we
can use the Microsoft soft Cloud app
security Azure ID application proxy
e-discovery and we have just in time
virtual machine access so on to the last
three pillars we have data so use
intelligence to classify and label data
encrypt and restrict access based on
organizational policies so we move from
perimeter-based data protection to
data-driven protection so here we can
use sensitivity labels Microsoft
information protection data
classification Azure information
protection scatter so AIP scanner does
decision-based policies and data loss
prevention policies all of this stuff
listed in the data pillar is in the
Microsoft 365 compliance Center this is
where all this stuff comes into play
which we'll see later on next we have
infrastructure so use Telemetry to
detect attacks and anomalies
automatically Block in flag risk
behaviors and employ at least privilege
access principles so here we can use the
Azure security Center Azure ID managed
identities user and resource
segmentation vnets hearing rules
privileged identity management network
security groups application security
groups Azure firewall Microsoft Defender
for endpoint Microsoft Defender for
identity and Azure Sentinel these last
three we'll be talking about in Greater
detail the last pillar here is Network
so ensure devices and users are not
trusted just because they're on an
internal Network encrypt all internal
Communications limit access by policy
and employee micro segmentation and
real-time threat detection so here we
can do Network segmentation Azure DDOS
Protection Service Azure firewall Azure
web application firewall also known as
Waf Azure VPN Azure ad proxy Azure
Bastion and SSL TLS so that's the zero
trust model six foundational pillars and
some of the related services that are
associated with each pillar
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at defense and
depth so defense in depth uses a layered
approach to security rather than relying
on a single perimeter a defense and
depth strategy uses a series of
mechanisms to slow the advance of an
attack there are seven layers of
security that Microsoft wants you to
know it's kind of similar to the shared
responsibility Model A lot of times we
see these things when organizations or
providers are talking about their
security centers like the actual data
centers and how they're secured but this
is more General it doesn't necessarily
have to apply to a data center but let's
go and work our way through inside out
at the core we have data so access to
business and customer data and
encryption to protect data then we have
application so applications are secure
and free of security vulnerabilities
then you have compute so access to VMS
ports on premises and cloudin then
Network so limit communication between
resources using segmentation and access
controls then you have perimeter so
distributed denial of service protection
to filter large-scale attacks before
they can cause a denial of service for
users identity and access so controlling
access to infrastructure and change
controls and then you have physical
security so limiting access to a data
center to only authorize Personnel so
the idea is that if you really want to
get to the data you've got to go through
all the steps here these are all the
layers of defense and so I just want to
give extra emphasis to Identity and
access because this one's the most outer
one besides the physical security so
they would say something like the modern
perimeter is defined based on your
identity another thing I want to mention
is that even though the perimeter layer
says it provides distributed denial of
service protection to filter large-scale
attacks and so on this is actually a bit
misleading the DDOS protection standard
provides multi-layered protection when
deployed with a web application firewall
it should protect both of the network
layer and at the application layer
emphasizing especially on the network
layer so here's an architecture of DDOS
protection standard being used you can
see that it will always be placed in the
network layer so it's applied to the
virtual Network work subnets network
security groups and so on a lot of
people get it confused with perimeter
layer when it should be the network
layer so that's defense and depth
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Azure active
directory also known as Azure ID and
it's Microsoft's cloud-based identity
and access management service which
helps your employees sign in and access
resources it's going to help us both
externally and with internal resources
so on the external side we're looking at
Microsoft 365 the Azure portal and SAS
applications and for internal resources
we have applications that reside within
your internal Network and access to
workstations that may reside on premise
one of the best features of azure ID is
single side on that's what a lot of
companies want it for in terms of what
types of azure active directory there
are it's broken down to four editions
with each subsequent tier having all the
features of the previous tier and so we
have the free tier where you get
multi-factor authentication single side
on basic security and usage reports and
user management we have Office 365 apps
so that will give you a company branding
service level agreement to sync between
on-premises and cloud and the last two I
I want you to take note of because we do
mention some of the features in this
course for these two tiers is premium
one and premium two also commonly
abbreviated to P1 and P2 so you have
hybrid architecture Advanced group
access and conditional access and for
premium 2 you have identity protection
identity governance so again as we move
up the tier each of the previous tier
has all the features of the prior one so
premium 2 has all the features of
Premium One in terms of the use case for
Azure ID it's for authorizing and
authenticating to multiple sources so
you can authorize and authenticate to
your on-premises active directory to
your web application it allows users to
log in with their identity provider IDP
like Facebook or Google and you can
connect to Microsoft 365 or Microsoft
Azure Azure ID takes care of all this
stuff and so when we're looking at
hybrid connections we're talking about
Azure dconnect when we're looking at
integrating our applications we're doing
this through app registrations where we
have the b2c service and then you have
external identities so that's going to
be for your identity any providers and
you can also easily integrate with Cloud
applications there's no particular
service or sub service for that Azure ID
naturally does that for you so let's
look at the comparison between active
directory versus Azure active directory
because they're not the same thing so
active directory has been around for
quite a long time Microsoft introduced
active directory domain services in
Windows 2000 to give organizations the
ability to manage multiple on-premises
infrastructure components and systems
using a single identity per user and so
Azure D takes this approach to the next
level by providing organizations with an
identity as a service solution for their
apps across cloud and on premises so
both versions are still used to this day
so there's active directory which is
used for on-premises and there's Azure
ID which is the cloud version and so we
see a lot of companies might want to
migrate over to Azure D or they might
have a particular Legacy licensing that
makes it more cost effective or there
might be certain security compliances
and that's why they're not using Azure
ID so both of these are still valid
product products just different use
cases
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Cloud
identity models so Microsoft 365 uses
Azure active directory a cloud-based
user identity and authentication Service
that's included with your Microsoft 365
subscription to manage identities and
authentication for Microsoft 365. it's
very important to set up your identity
infrastructure properly if you want to
manage Microsoft 365 user access and
permissions for your company so there
are two identity models available in
Microsoft 365. the first one is cloud
only identity this is where you maintain
your organization's identities only in
the cloud and the Azure d-tenant for
your Microsoft 365 subscription performs
the authentication with the cloud
identity account the second one is
hybrid identity this is where you
maintain your on-premises active
directory domain Services identities and
use them for authentication when users
access Microsoft 365 cloud services and
the Azure d-tenant for your Microsoft
365 subscription handles the
authentication process or redirects the
user to another identity provider we'll
talk more about the two identity models
in Greater detail later
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a closer look at the
cloud only identity model so a cloud
only identity uses user accounts that
exist only in Azure ID it's typically
used by small organizations that do not
have on-premises servers or do not use a
DDS to manage local identities both on
premises and remote users use their
Azure ID user accounts and passwords to
access Microsoft 365 cloud services
Azure a de-authenticates user
credentials based on its stored user
accounts and passwords in terms of
administration you manage Cloud
identities with tools such as the
Microsoft 365 admin Center and windows
Powershell because user accounts are
only stored in Azure ID and so this is
best for organizations that do not have
or needed on premises of DDS and their
greatest benefit would be that it's
simple to use and it requires no extra
directory tools or servers so looking at
the visual here within your organization
you have your on-premises users and your
remote users and both of them can access
Microsoft 365 with Azure ID using their
user accounts all on the cloud so that's
the cloud only identity model
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a more in-depth look at
the Hybrid identity model so hybrid
identity uses accounts that originate in
an on-premises a DDS and have a copy in
the Azure a detented of a Microsoft 365
subscription any changes that you make
to a DDS user accounts are synchronized
to their copy in Azure ID except for
specific account attributes Azure a
dconnect provides the ongoing account
synchronization so this runs on an
on-premises server checks for changes in
the DDS and forwards those changes to
Azure ID Azure dconnect provides the
ability to filter which accounts are
synchronized and whether to synchronize
a hash version of user passwords known
as password hash synchronization Azure a
d password hash synchronization is the
simplest way to enable authentication
for on-premises directory objects in
Azure ID continuing out with hybrid
identity your on-premises of DDS is the
authoritative source for account
information when you implement hybrid
identity the Azure d-tenant has a copy
of the DDS accounts both on premises and
remote users accessing Microsoft 36 65
cloud services authenticate against
Azure ID so hybrid identity is best for
organizations using a DDS or another
identity provider and its greatest
benefit is that users can use the same
credentials when accessing on-premises
or cloud-based resources so it's very
convenient to use looking at the visual
here you have your active directory
domain Services accounts and you have
servers running Azure dconnect to
synchronize and copy the accounts to
Azure ID through this both on premises
and remote users can access Microsoft
365 to utilize all its apps in cloud
services so that's the hybrid identity
model
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be taking a look at
multifactor authentication also known as
MFA and that's how we'll refer to it
throughout the entire course so NFA is a
security control that provides an extra
level of security where after you fill
in your email and password you have to
use a second device such as a phone to
confirm that you are the owner of the
account to log in MFA protects against
people who have stolen your password
when you're dealing with the
verification method it must be based on
something you have with you that isn't
easily duplicated such as a phone like
we mentioned before it could also be
something uniquely and biologically have
such as your fingerprints face or other
biometric attribute by default both
Microsoft 365 and Office 365 support MFA
for user accounts using a text message
sent to a phone that requires the user
to type a verification code a phone call
and the Microsoft authenticator
smartphone app so there are multiple
ways you can enable MFA for Microsoft
365 in office 365. the first one is with
security defaults then we have with
conditional access policies and for each
individual user account which is not
recommended MFA is available in all
Microsoft 365 plans however if you want
to gain features such as security
defaults or conditional access policies
you'll need to get Microsoft 365
business premium or Microsoft 365 E3
there's even Microsoft 365 E5 if you
want Azure identity protection so here
is an example where you see my email my
password and that is called one factor
so I've confirmed my identity like in
this one case and then you have the
second Factor also known as multi-factor
that's usually what we call it and in
this case we are sent a verification
code to our phone to confirm and that's
going to let us get into the system so
that's MFA
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be taking a look at
conditional access which provides an
extra layer of security before allowing
authenticated users to access data or
other assets so conditional access is
implemented through conditional access
policies which are a set of rules that
specify the conditions under which
sign-ins are evaluated and allowed for
example you can create a conditional
access policy that states if the user
account name is a member of a group for
users that are assigned The Exchange
user password security SharePoint or
Global administrator roles require MFA
before allowing access this policy
allows you to require MFA based on group
membership rather than trying to
configure individual user accounts for
MFA when they're assigned or unassigned
from these administrator roles so a
conditional access policy analyzes
signals signal could be user and
location device application real-time
risk and we'll go more into detail with
all the types of signals in the next
slide and the idea is you need to verify
every access attempt through Access
Control you might have required MFA
Locker access and allow access so here
is a visual I got from the Microsoft
documentation the idea here is you have
your signal and you have your user in
location application real-time risk and
device and here we have to verify every
access attempt to meet the conditional
access policies that were set to gain
access to our apps and data so let's
take a closer look at signals signals is
metadata associated with an identity
attempting to gain access and we'll be
going over the full list of signals that
are possible conditional access starting
with users or group membership so
policies Target specific users and
groups including admin roles giving
admins fine grain control over access
then you could have signals that are
named location or IP location
information so that's a range of ips
used when making policy decisions so
admins can opt to block or allow traffic
from an entire country's IP ranges for
devices users with devices of specific
platforms are marked with a specific
State can be used for applications users
attempting to access specific
applications can trigger different
additional access policies real-time
cited risk detection so signals
integration with Azure ID identity
protection allows conditional access
policies to identify sign and behavior
and policies can then Force users to
perform password changes or multi-factor
authentication to reduce the risk level
or be blocked from access until
administrator takes manual action then
you have your Cloud apps or Cloud
actions so Cloud apps or actions can
include or exclude Cloud applications or
user actions that will be subject to
policy then there's user risks so from
customers with access to Identity
protection user risks can be evaluated
as part of the conditional access policy
user risk represents the probability
that a given Identity or account is
compromised let's talk about common
decisions so these Define the access
control that Define what level of access
based on the signal information and so
this is when we were talking about that
verifying steps these are those common
decisions so we have block access which
is the most restrictive decision then
you have Grant access and this is the
least restrictive decision but still
requires is one or more of the following
options so there's require MFA required
device to be marked as compliant require
hybrid Azure a dejoin device require
approved Client app and require app
protection policy another important
thing to know is that you can use
conditional access policies with
Microsoft 365 business premium Microsoft
365 E3 and E5 and Azure at D premium P1
and Azure D premium P2 licenses so
that's the value of conditional access
and how you can use conditional access
policies to increase your level of
security
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to enable
multi-factor authentication for
Microsoft 365 users in the Microsoft 365
admin Center there are a couple ways to
do this but the easiest way is from the
Microsoft 365 admin Center so the first
thing you want to do is to go to your
app store on your smartphone Android or
iOS you want to search for Microsoft
authenticator and once you've found it
you just download it and install it onto
your phone ready to enable the MFA the
next section requires you to go to the
Microsoft 365 admin page if you work for
a business you may not have access to
this so you'll need to get it from your
it department or get your it support
company to do this for you once you're
in the Microsoft 365 admin page you need
to navigate to the users and then active
users along the top right pane along the
top here you'll see a button called
multi-factor authentication so you click
on that and it'll populate the list of
users so for this demonstration we'll
use the demo user Sam do we created
earlier so you see here it says the
multi-factor Authentication station
status is disabled so we select Sam do
and we click on enable and click on
enable multi-factor Authentication
now the user Sam do is enabled for
multi-factor authentication but we need
to validate this change so you'll need
to go the Microsoft 365 login page or
Office 365 login page
first we'll need to site in with another
account which is Sam do
I will sign in as the user Sam do with
the username and password I'm just going
to copy and paste these in here let's
just see what happens here once we enter
the password now because we've enabled
it in the back end of Microsoft 365.
it's asking us to enable multi-factor
authentication so it's saying your
organization needs more information to
keep your account secure so let's click
on next
so now it's telling us to install
Microsoft authenticator as the type of
MFA there are a few other ways to set
this up such as authentication phone or
office phone but we're going to use
mobile app for this demonstration as
we've downloaded Microsoft
authentication earlier so we want to
receive notifications for verification
so we'll click on next the next thing
you want to do is go to your phone and
open the Microsoft authentication app
and the first thing you want to do is to
click on the three dots on the top right
and click on add account so we click on
add account we should select worker
school account and then you'll get a
little prob saying scan QR code so we
click on there and all we simply do now
is point your phone at the computer
screen and it'll scan the QR code just
wait a couple of seconds and then it'll
list it in your authenticator app so you
click on the email address so back onto
your screen click on next to proceed
so now we'll be able to test this out so
on your device it's saying please
respond to the notification and it will
tell your device to approve this site on
so you click on approve and it should be
successful
the notification has been approved and
so you click on next
the Microsoft authenticator app has been
successfully registered so we click done
since it's our first time signing on the
user Sam do we'll need to create a new
password for the user
after that's complete the user should be
able to successfully log in and the next
time the user attempts to sign in you'll
need to approve using the Microsoft
authenticator app multi-factor
authentication method again
so that's how you enable multi-factor
authentication on your Microsoft 365
user
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look here at
Microsoft 365 Defender which is a
unified pre and post breach Enterprise
defense Suite that natively coordinates
responses such as detection prevention
and investigation across endpoints
identities emails and applications to
provide integrated protection against
sophisticated attacks so Microsoft 365
Defender allows admins to assess threat
signals from endpoints applications
email and identities to determine an
attack scope and impact it provides
detailed Insight on how the threat
occurred and what systems were affected
Microsoft 365 Defender can then take
automated action to prevent or stop the
attack so if you're looking for where
the service is you'd open up the portal
at office.com and find it on the side
menu and click on security that's where
you'll find Microsoft 365 Defender so
Microsoft 365 Defender is composed of
the following Services it has Microsoft
Defender for identity Microsoft Defender
for endpoint Microsoft Defender for
cloud apps preview obviously known as
Microsoft Cloud app security then
there's Microsoft Defender for Office
365 Microsoft 365 Defender portal and
Microsoft secure score here's just a
graphic to reiterate over those four
Services the ones in Boulder the core
services but we'll be going more into
detail of all of them later so that's
Microsoft 365 Defender
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we'll be talking about Microsoft
Defender for endpoint So within
Microsoft 365 we have endpoints and
these are a set of destination IP
addresses DNS domain names and URLs for
Microsoft 365 traffic on the internet so
to optimize performance for M365
cloud-based Services these endpoints
need special handling by client browsers
and the devices in your Edge Network and
these devices include firewalls SSL
break and inspect and packet inspection
devices and data loss prevention systems
here is an image showing what it looks
like again it's just IP addresses and
DNS domain names so endpoints are
grouped into four service areas exchange
online SharePoint online and OneDrive
for business Skype for business online
and Microsoft teams and M365 common in
office online so it's just a bunch of
these things here on the left hand side
but it's specialized for those
particular areas so now taking a look
here at Microsoft Defender for endpoint
is an Enterprise endpoint security
platform designed to help Enterprise
networks prevent detect investigate and
respond to Advanced threats and so
Defender for in point uses the following
combination of Technologies built into
Windows 10 and Microsoft cloud service
so we have in point behavioral sensors
which are embedded in Windows 10 the
sensors collect and process behavioral
signals from the operating system and
send this sensor data to your private
isolated Cloud instances of Microsoft
Defender for endpoint then you have
Cloud security analytics so this is
leveraging Big Data device learning and
unique Microsoft Optics across the
windows ecosystem Enterprise Cloud
products such as Office 365 and online
assets behavioral signals are translated
into insights detections and recommended
responses to Advanced threats then we
have threatened intelligence this is
generated by Microsoft Hunter's security
teams and augmented by threat
intelligence providers by Partners
threat intelligence enables Defender for
endpoint to identify attack attacker
tools techniques procedures and generate
alerts when they are observed in
collected sensor data so that's
Microsoft 365 Defender for endpoint and
all the Technologies it uses to prevent
Advanced threats
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft 365
Defender for identity so Defender for
identity is a cloud-based security
solution that leverages your on-premise
active directory data which are called
signals to identify detect and
investigate Advanced threats compromised
identities and malicious Insider actions
directed at your organization it detects
Advanced attacks in hybrid environments
to monitor users entity behavior and
activities with learning based analytics
it protects user identities and
credentials stored in active directory
identify and investigate suspicious user
activities and advanced attacks
throughout the kill chain and provide
clear incident information on a simple
timeline for fast triage so going into
more depth with the things we just
talked about for Monitor and profile
user behavior and activities Defender
for identity monitors and analyzes user
activities and information across your
network including permissions and group
membership creating a behavioral
Baseline for each user for protect Tech
user identities and reduce the attack
surface it provides insights on identity
configurations and suggested security
best practices and through security
reports and user profile analytics it
helps reduce your organizational attack
surface making it harder to compromise
user credentials and Advance an attack
for identify suspicious activities and
advanced attacks across the Cyber attack
kill chain Defender for identity
identifies these Advanced threats of the
source throughout the entire Cyber
attack kill chain reconnaissance
compromise credentials lateral movements
and domain dominance you can use the
defender for identity attack timeline
view and the intelligence of smart
analytics to stay focused on what
matters also you can use Defender for
identity to quickly investigate threats
and gain insights across the
organization for users devices and
network resources so Microsoft Defender
for identity monitors your domain
controllers by capturing and parsing
Network traffic and leveraging windows
events directly from your domain
controllers that analyzes the data for
attacks and threats so here is the
architecture sure of it first we have
our domain controller over here then we
have Microsoft Defender for identity
then it's going to go to the Microsoft
Cloud app security which is now the
Microsoft Defender for apps so that we
can do some analysis later on you could
pass it over to sim integration or Azure
Sentinel for some security information
or event management as well and things
like that so by utilizing profiling
deterministic detection machine learning
behavioral algorithms Defender for
identity learns about your network
enables detection of for anomalies and
warns you of suspicious activities and
that's Defender for identity hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we'll be
taking a look at Microsoft Defender for
office 365. so Microsoft Defender for
Office 365 protects against Advanced
threats by email messages links URLs
Microsoft teams SharePoint online
OneDrive for business and other clients
and protection is provided via reports
thread investigations threat responses
and threat protection policies and
there's three available subscriptions we
have exchange online protection the
defender for Office 365 plan 1 and plan
two and Office 365 security Builds on
the core protections offered by EOP so
EOP is present in any subscription where
exchange online mailboxes can be found
so going into more detail here for EOP
it's a cloud-based filtering service
that protects your organizations against
spam malware and other email threats the
defender for office P1 provides safe
attachment which checks email
attachments for malicious content safe
links where the links are scanned for
each clicking A Safe Link remains
accessible but malicious links are
blocked it provides protection for
SharePoint OneDrive and Microsoft teams
it identifies and blocks malicious files
and team sites and document libraries
anti-phishing protection so this detects
attempts to impersonate your users and
internal or custom domains real-time
detection it's a real-time report that
allows you to identify and analyze
recent threats the defender for office
P2 this includes all the defender office
sp1 features so we have threat trackers
the latest Intelligence on cyber
security issues takes counter
measurements before an actual threat we
have threat Explorer so real-time
reports that allows you to identify and
analyze recent threats automated
investigation and response also known as
air is a set of security playbooks that
can be launched automatically start an
automatic investigation provide detailed
reports recommend Action Security teams
can approve there's a tax simulator you
can run realistic attack scenarios in
your organization to identify for
vulnerabilities so you can see that P2
is very very good it provides a lot of
great features here's a bit more detail
on the EOP so once again it's a
cloud-based filtering service that
protects your organization from spam
malware and other email threats here is
a graphic displaying how it works in all
the processes it undergoes and so EOP
has features for anti-malware inbound
anti-spam how about anti-spam connection
filtering anti-fishing anti-spoofing
protection 0 zero hour auto Purge for
delivered malware spam and phishing
messages preset security policies tenant
allow in block list allow block lists
for message senders directory base Edge
blocking mail flow rules accepted
domains message training and more
another important thing to know is that
Microsoft Defender for Office 365 is
included in the Microsoft 365e5 Office
365 E5 and A5 and Microsoft 365 business
premium subscriptions so you can see
there's a lot of features and I just
couldn't fit them all on the screen but
I just wanted to show you how valuable
exchange online protection is and this
is one of the many advantages it has
over Gmail
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Microsoft
Defender portal so we've said before
that Microsoft 365 Defender natively
coordinates detection prevention
investigation and response across
endpoints identities email and
applications to provide integrated
protection against sophisticated attacks
while the Microsoft 365 Defender portal
brings all of those functionalities
together into one place focusing on
getting quick access to information and
providing simple layouts to meet the
needs of security teams you can view the
security health of your organization
through the Microsoft 365 Defender
portal some of the key features of the
Microsoft 365 Defender portal include
incidents and alerts which create alerts
when they detect a suspicious or
malicious event or activity threat
analytics designed to assist security
teams track and respond to emerging
threats the secure score which is a
representation of a company's security
posture and will be going more into
detail about it later Learning Hub which
provides official guidance from
resources like Microsoft security Block
in the official documentation and
reports which can be a general security
report and Branch into specific reports
about in points email and collaboration
so the Microsoft 365 Defender portal
home page shows many of the common cards
that security teams need the card and
data composition is determined by the
user's role different roles will see
cards that are more relevant to their
day-to-day jobs because the Microsoft
365 Defender portal uses role-based
access restriction the cards fall into
these categories identities monitor the
identities in your organization and keep
track of suspicious or risky behaviors
data help track user activity that could
lead to unauthorized data disclosure
devices get up-to-date information on
alerts for each activity and other
threats on your devices apps gain
insight into how Cloud apps are being
used in your organization so that's
Microsoft Defender portal
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
Defender for cloud apps which is a cloud
access security broker that sits between
the user and the cloud service provider
to gatekeep access in real time to Cloud
resources Microsoft Defender for cloud
apps is built on a framework that
follows four principles the first one is
discover and control the use of Shadow
it identify the cloud apps and iOS and
pass Services used by your organization
investigate usage patterns assess the
risk levels and business Readiness of
more than twenty five thousand PSIs apps
against more than 80 risks then we have
protect against cyber threats and
anomalies detect unusual behavior across
Cloud apps to identify ransomware
compromised users or Rogue applications
analyze high risk usage and remediate
automatically to limit the risk to your
organization then there's protect your
sensitive information anywhere in the
cloud understand classify and protect
the exposure of sensitive information at
rest leverage out of the box policies
and automated processes to apply
controls in real time across all your
Cloud apps and then we have assessed the
compliance of your Cloud apps assess if
your Cloud apps meet relevant compliance
requirements including Regulatory
Compliance and Industry standards
prevent data leaks to non-compliant apps
and limit access to regulated data so
let's look at the architecture of
Defender for cloud apps and some of the
functionalities Microsoft Defender for
cloud apps integrates visibility with
your Cloud by using Cloud Discovery to
map and identify your Cloud environment
and the cloud apps your organization is
using sanctioning and unsanctioning apps
in your Cloud using easy to deploy app
connectors that take advantage of
provider apis for visibility and
governance of apps that you connect to
using conditional access app control
protection to get real-time visibility
and control over access and activities
within your Cloud apps helping you have
continuous control by setting and then
continually fine-tuning policies so
that's Microsoft Defender for cloud apps
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
secure score So within Microsoft 365
Defender you get a secure score and this
is a representation of your
organization's security posture and your
opportunity to improve it through
Improvement actions this is similar to
Azure defender's secure score but they
have slightly different terminology to
make it a little more company friendly
towards people that are developers so on
the right here you are given a secure
score which is currently at 18.25
percent and of course the higher the
score the better your protection and
then you see the Improvement actions
which shows you all the actions you can
perform to increase your secure score to
improve your organization's security
posture so organizations can monitor and
work on the security of their Microsoft
365 identities apps and devices from a
centralized dashboard via the Microsoft
365 Defender portal secure score helps
organizations report on the current
state of their security posture improve
their security posture by providing
discoverability visibility guidance and
control compare benchmarks and establish
key performance indicators currently
Microsoft's secure score supports
recommendations for Microsoft 365
including exchange online Azure active
directory Microsoft Defender for
endpoint Microsoft Defender for identity
Microsoft Defender Cloud apps and
Microsoft teams also new recommendations
are being added to secure score all the
time so that's Microsoft's secure score
[Music]
this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and
we'll be talking about Microsoft 365
security reports So within Microsoft 365
you have security reports and these are
General Security dashboards about
security trends for Microsoft 365
identities device and apps information
is organized into cards on the dashboard
so you have identities where we'll have
users at risk in global admins then you
have devices so devices at risk device
compliance devices with active malware
types of malware on devices malware on
devices devices with malware detection
and users with malware detections then
you have apps which have risk levels and
so all of this information can be
reorganized or grouped into category or
topic so right now we have identities
devices and apps for the topics we could
have risk detection threads and
configuration and health so just to kind
of tell you a little bit more here
imagine you have a bunch of these cards
and they're broken down by all these
categories here so you can have a bird's
eye view of what's going on on one
particular report that is interesting to
show you is the Office 365 exchange
which is a mail server so this provides
email collaboration reports it gives you
Statistics over time if you were to
drill down into a particular type of
report here you can kind of see things
like spoof detections spam detections
over time and things like that so that
security reports
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about common
threats before we talk about the common
threats we need to know what our
vulnerabilities so a vulnerability as a
whole or a potential weakness in the
application which can be a design flaw
or an implementation bug that allows an
attacker to infiltrate an organization
or cause harm to the stakeholders of an
application now that leads us to threats
a threat in Cloud security is a
potential negative action or event
facilitated by a vulnerability that
results in an unwanted impact to a
computer system or application attackers
will create threats across multiple
domains like email identity and points
and applications to find a point of
lease resistance today's defense
Solutions have been designed to protect
detect and block threats for each domain
separately allow the attackers to
exploit the seams and threshold
differences between Solutions leaving
the business vulnerable to attack so now
we'll be talking about the most common
threats Microsoft wants to focus on
credential theft is a type of cyber
crime that involves stealing a victim's
proof of identity examples of credential
theft or mimikatz password spray or
breach harvesting malware also known as
malicious software is a file or code
typically delivered over a network that
infects explores steals or conducts
virtually any Behavior an attacker wants
examples of malware are viruses
ransomware and adware phishing attacks
use tricks or lures to get a user to
reveal credentials or pay money
typically by getting them to click a
link to a fake website in an email that
appears genuine examples of phishing
attacks are email phishing and spear
fishing infrastructure attacks include
improperly secured virtual machines and
resources in Azure examples of
infrastructure attacks include dos and
DDOS attacks so these are the common
threats that Microsoft wants you to be
familiar with there's definitely more
than just four types but these are the
main ones that Microsoft wants to focus
on
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be taking a look at how
Microsoft addresses the most common
threats so we'll be talking about
Microsoft 365 Defender and how it
protects us from potential threats and
vulnerabilities this may seem like a
review for you but it's great to note
nonetheless Microsoft 365 Defender is an
integrated cross-domain threat detection
and response solution that provides
organizations with the ability to
prevent detect investigate and remediate
sophisticated cross-domain attacks
within their Microsoft 365 environments
it leverages raw signal data from
Individual service domains like user
identity and points applications email
and collaboration tools normalizing the
data at the ingestion Point Microsoft
365 Defender requires no specific
expertise or customization so Defenders
can immediately use the integrated
console and combine incident views with
Microsoft 365 Defender security teams
can automatically block attacks and
eliminate their persistence to keep them
from starting again prioritize incidents
investigation in response Auto heal
assets Focus unique expertise on Cross
domain hunting Microsoft 365 Defender
Suite protects and points with Microsoft
Defender for endpoint a unified endpoint
platform for preventative protection
post breach detection automated
investigation and response email in
collaboration with Microsoft Defender
for Office 365 safeguards your
organization against malicious threats
posed by email messages links and
collaboration tools identities with
Microsoft Defender for identity and
Azure active directory identity
protection uses active directory signals
to identify detect and investigate
Advanced threats compromise identities
and malicious Insider actions directed
at your organization applications with
Microsoft Defender for cloud apps a
comprehensive Crosshair solution
bringing deep visibility strong data
controls and enhanced threat protection
to your Cloud apps so these are the main
tools and services that Microsoft uses
to detect and eliminate any potential
threats to your Microsoft 365
environment
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
Sentinel also known as Azure Sentinel so
Microsoft Sentinel is a scalable Cloud
native security information and event
management so Siem and security
orchestration Automation and response
Solutions or Microsoft Sentinel delivers
intelligent security analytics and
threat intelligence across the
Enterprise providing a single solution
for alert and attack detection threat
visibility proactive hunting and threat
response so here's a big wheel that
Microsoft Sentinel likes to use to
describe it and what's cool about this
offering is it's both a Siam and a sore
so you don't have to have two separate
Services starting off with collected so
collect data at Cloud scale across all
users devices applications and
infrastructure both on premise and in
multiple clouds detect previously
undetected threats and minimize false
positives using Microsoft's analytics
and unparalleled thread intelligence
investigate threats with artificial
intelligence and hunt for suspicious
activities at scale all tapping into
years of cyber security work at
Microsoft respond to incidents rapidly
with built-in orchestration and
automation of common tasks let's take a
look at what Microsoft Sentinel can
ingest from other data set sources so we
have a number of connectors here such as
Microsoft 365 Defender Microsoft 365
sources including Office 365 Azure ID
Microsoft Defender for identity and
Microsoft Defender for cloud apps you
can also use common event formats such
as syslog rest API Windows event logs
common event format and trusted
automated exchange of indicator
information also known as taxii so let's
take a look at workbooks and so this is
a feature of azure monitor but Microsoft
Sentinel allows you to create workbooks
really easily after you connected your
data sources to Microsoft Sentinel you
can monitor the data using the Microsoft
Sentinel integration with Azure monitor
workbooks workbooks provide a flexible
canvas for data analysis and the
creation of Rich visual reports they
allow you to tap into multiple data data
sources and combine them into unified
interactive experiences it tells a story
about the performance and availability
about your applications and services so
here's a graph showing the performance
analysis and here's another one showing
the application failure analysis but the
idea is that these are kind of like
living documents where you can visualize
and monitor specific metrics and other
things about your applications and
services Microsoft Sentinel allows you
to create custom workbooks across your
data and also comes with built-in
workbook templates to allow you to
quickly gain insights across your data
as soon as you connect a data source a
couple more points here on workbooks is
that they are intended for sock
engineers and analysts of all tiers to
visualize data sock stands for security
operations center if you didn't know
while workbooks are best used for high
level views of Microsoft Sentinel data
and require no coding knowledge you
cannot integrate workbooks with external
data now let's look at the core features
of Microsoft Sentinel starting with
analytics so Microsoft Sentinel uses
analytics to correlate alerts into
incidents so over here we can see that
we have list them in incidents or groups
of related alerts that together create
an actionable possible threat that you
can investigate and resolve Microsoft
Sentinel also provides machine learning
rules to map your network behavior and
then look for anomalies across your
resources then there's Automation and
orchestration so with Sentinel you have
solutions that provide a highly
extensible architecture that enables
scalable automation as new technologies
and threats emerge Sentinel is built on
the foundation of azure logic apps so
it's a great way of not having to use
any code but you can chain things over
different services and they have over
200 connectors for services such as
Azure functions the connectors allow you
to apply any custom logic and code
servicenow jira zendesk HTTP requests
Microsoft teams slack Windows Defender
at TP and Defender for cloud apps so
there's a lot to do there for
investigations the investigation tools
help you to understand the scope and
find the root cause of a potential
security threat you can choose an entity
on the interactive graph to ask
interesting questions for a specific
entity and drill down into that entity
and its connections to get to the root
cause of the threat moving on to hunting
so Microsoft sentinel's powerful hunting
search and query tools is based on the
miter framework which is a curated
knowledge base that tracks cyber
adversary tactics and techniques so this
enables you to proactively hunt for
security threats across your
organization's data sources before an
alert is triggered after you discover
which hunting query provides high value
insights into possible attacks you can
also create custom detection rules based
on your query and service those insights
as alerts to your security incident
responders while hunting you can create
bookmarks for interesting events
enabling you to return to them later
share them with others and group them
with other correlating events to create
a compelling incident for investigation
and on to our final section we'll go
over the pricing models of Microsoft
Sentinel so the first type is capacity
reservations where you are billed a
fixed fee base on the selected tier
enabling a predictable total cost for
Microsoft Sentinel and we have pay as
you go so your bill per gigabyte for the
volume of data ingested for analysis in
Microsoft Sentinel and stored in the
Azure monitor log analytics workspace so
that's Microsoft Sentinel
[Music]
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we're
going through an overview of the
Microsoft 365 Defender we'll be taking a
look at only the key features here so in
general Microsoft 365 Defender helps
respond to threats and manage security
across your identities data devices apps
and infrastructure so starting with the
incidents and alerts section there is
currently no data because this is a new
account and no alerts have been recorded
typically there would be a list of
incidents and alerts it would include
the incident name a unique ID number the
severity of the threat status and
displays a summary of the incident and
provides access to tabs with additional
information one of the key features of
the Microsoft 365 Defender is the secure
score so the Microsoft secure score is a
representation of your organization's
security posture and your opportunity to
improve it it's similar to how the
Microsoft compliance score is designed
here it displays the secure score of
28.07 percent for the organization and
right next to it shows a list of actions
to review it also provides a comparison
of your organization's secure score to
other organizations that is similarly
set up or designed to other
organizations with their secure score
the next thing we want to do is to click
on recommended actions this will
populate the list of actions to review
so on the list of actions to review we
can sort them however we want such as
according to their rank score impact
points achieved status and so on and
once you complete the recommended action
it will increase your security score
based on the score impact of the action
as an example we'll select a simple one
such as only invited users should be
automatically admitted to teams meetings
then we'll click on implementation which
are the instructions or guide where to
go and how to complete the action so
this tells us to go to the Microsoft
teams admin Center and in the meeting
policies under the participants and
guests section toggle automatically
admit people to invited users only so
we'll click on Microsoft teams admin
Center first thing you'll want to do is
to navigate to the on meetings pane then
click on meeting policies
and then on manage policies click on the
add button we'll need to give this
policy a name so we'll name it invite
users only
then we'll need to look for the policy
mentioned in the implementation
after finding the correct section of
participants and guests under the
automatically admit people will need to
toggle and change it to invited users
only then click save
you can now see that the new policy has
been added to the list so that should be
completed and you should see the secure
score update within 24 hours coming back
to the Microsoft secure section there's
a tab that displays the history of your
Microsoft secure score to see the
performance over a period of time if it
increases or decreases you can also view
metrics and Trends such as comparison
Trend regression Trend and risk
acceptance Trend that you may be
interested in
for the reports section there is the
general section where you can view
information about security Trends and
track the protection status of your
identities data devices apps and
infrastructure there's also the email
and collaboration reports where you
review Microsoft recommended actions to
help improve email and collaboration
security and many more but we're not
going to go through all of them the
audit section should be similar to the
one in the Microsoft purview compliance
portal so we won't go over too much the
last section we'll talk about is the
health section and the main thing we
want to look at here is service health
so here you can view the issues and
health status of all services that are
available with your current
subscriptions you can view info about
the history of incidents and advisories
that have been resolved and you can
track the status of issues reported by
people in your organization over the
last 30 days so that's a quick overview
of the Microsoft 365 Defender
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Regulatory
Compliance so what is compliance it's
conforming to a rule such as a
specification policy standard or law and
Regulatory compliances and organization
that takes effort to comply with
relevant laws policies and regulations
so Regulatory Compliance can vary at the
following levels so there's Federal such
as Canada there's state or provincial
like Ontario political and economic
Union like European union and
international organization so why do we
have Regulatory Compliance well
governments want to protect its citizens
data that is collected by companies and
organizations we don't want the
companies or Orcs to mishandle our data
or sell our data what are compliance
controls well those are internal control
mechanisms that need to be in place to
detect prevent incorrect compliance
issues for example we have public
standards and policies documented
procedures training monitoring and
internal audits so what are some of the
measures that Regulatory Compliance can
enforce well it allows citizens the
right to access their data at any time
citizens have the right to correct or
delete data if needed it gives us
control over the retention periods for
the minimum or maximum time data should
be stored enabling governments and
Regulatory Agencies the right to access
and examine data when necessary and
defining rules for what data can be
processed and how that should be done so
that's Regulatory Compliance
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at compliance
Solutions in Microsoft 365 which are
collections of integrated capabilities
you can use to help you manage
end-to-end compliance scenarios a
Solutions capabilities and tools might
include a combination of policies alerts
reports and more the solution catalog is
organized into sections that contain
information cards for each compliance
solution available in your Microsoft 365
subscription each section contains cards
for Solutions grouped by compliance area
so you can see on the image here there's
the information and protection area
Insider risk management Discovery
response and so on and within them you
have the solution cards like
communication compliance when you select
view for a solution card you'll see
detailed information about the
compliance solution and how to get
started so we're looking at the
communication compliance section and
this information includes an overview
pre-configuration requirements learning
resources controls that allow you to pin
the car to the navigation Pane and an
option to share the solution as a Link
email or Microsoft teams message to view
the Microsoft purview solution catalog
go to
compliance.microsoft.com and sign in as
a global administrator compliance
administrator or compliance data
administrator select catalog in the
navigation pane on the left side of the
screen to open the catalog home page so
that's the compliance Solutions in
Microsoft 365.
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be talking about the service
trust portal so the Microsoft service
trust portal provides a variety of
content tools and other resources about
Microsoft security privacy and
compliance practices from the main menu
you can access the service trust portal
compliancemanager trust documents
Industries and regions trust Center
Resources by library and more and we'll
briefly go over what each section has to
offer in the next slide so the service
trust portal provides a quick way to get
back to the home page for the service
trust portal to compliance manager
directs users to compliance manager in
the Microsoft purview compliance portal
to access to compliance manager and
other compliance management capabilities
in Microsoft 365. we'll talk a bit more
about this later on trust documents
provides a wealth of security
implementation and design information
with the goal of making it easier for
organizations to meet Regulatory
Compliance objectives so with interest
documents there are audit reports which
provide a list of independent audit and
assessment reports on Microsoft's cloud
services is displayed data protection
contains a wealth of resources such as
audited controls white papers FAQs
penetration tests risk assessment tools
and compliance guides Azure stack
contains documents that provide security
and compliance Solutions and support
tailored to the needs of azure stack
customers Industries and regions
provides access to compliance
information about Microsoft cloud
services organized by industry and
region you can access the industry
Solutions which directs users to the
landing page for the financial services
industry containing information such as
compliance offerings FAQs and success
stories and there's Regional Solutions
which provide documents on Microsoft
cloud services compliance with the laws
of various countries regions including
Australia Canada Czech Republic Denmark
Germany Poland Romania Spain and the
United Kingdom trust Center links you to
the Microsoft trust Center which
provides more information about privacy
security and compliance in the Microsoft
cloud resources provide links to
security and compliance for Office 365
the Microsoft global data centers and
FAQs and my library is a feature that
lets you save documents so that you can
quickly access them on your my library
page taking a closer look at audit
reports and so audit reports are
independent audit reports for
Microsoft's cloud services which provide
information about compliance with data
protection standards and regulatory
requirements so you'll get audit reports
for it International Organization for
standardization service organization
controls National Institute of Standards
and Technology Federal risk and
authorization Management program and
general data protection regulation so
you'll get a list of documents and PDFs
that you can download you can open them
up and see how Microsoft and Azure are
being compliant and just taking a closer
look at Regional Solutions in the
industries and regions section so as we
mentioned before Regional Solutions
provide documents on Microsoft's
compliance policies and regulations for
Regions such as Australia Germany UK and
many more and so here here you can
select the regions that are available
and in this example it's United Kingdom
and here you can look at the GRC
assessment reports their description and
you can download them for a closer
inspection so that's the service trust
portal
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at compliance
Concepts focusing on data residency and
how it helps ensure Regulatory
Compliance so as organizations and
institutions move their data to service
provider clouds with data centers all
over the world government agencies and
Industry groups have issued regulations
to help protect and govern the use of
data organizations can be accountable
for meeting dozens of regulations
ranging from personal and financial
information to data protection and
privacy so when it comes to compliance
data residency regulations govern the
physical locations where data can be
stored as well as how and when it can be
transferred processed or accessed
internationally these regulations can
differ significantly depending on
jurisdiction it ensures customers can
access diagnostic service generated and
support data and can manage access to
their own data Microsoft protects
customer data from unauthorized access
and handles challenges from government
requests and other third-party orders it
provides tools customers can use to
restrict protect and encrypt data at
rest in transit and in some cases in use
it enforces strict policies and
practices that Microsoft follows for the
retention and deletion of customer data
Microsoft also ensures compliance with
privacy regulations and standards to
help protect the privacy of customer
data so here are some important Concepts
and terms that relate to data compliance
that you may need to know data
sovereignty is the concept that data
particularly personal data is subject to
the laws and regulations of the country
region in which it's physically
collected held or processed this can
complicate compliance because the same
piece of data can be collected in one
location stored in another and processed
in another making it subject to laws
from different countries and regions and
data privacy is providing notice and
being transparent about the collection
processing use and sharing of personal
data are fundamental principles of
privacy laws and regulations personal
data means any information relating to
an identified or identifiable natural
person privacy laws previously
referenced Pi or personally identifiable
info information but the laws have
expanded the definition to any data that
is directly linked or indirectly
linkable back to a person organizations
are subject to and must operate
consistent with a multitude of laws
regulations codes of conduct
industry-specific standards and
compliance standards governing data
privacy so those are the compliance
Concepts
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're talking about Microsoft
purview information protection also
known as Microsoft information
protection and this is a collection of
features within Microsoft purview
formerly Microsoft 365 compliance to
help you discover classify and protect
sensitive information wherever it lives
or travels so the idea here is that we
have this diagram and we have four
specific domains that are information
protection capabilities around our data
and so the first is know your data the
second is protect your data the third is
prevent data loss and the fourth is
govern your data so we'll be going over
all these sections in the next few
slides taking a look at the four domains
here for the Microsoft purview
information protection these are
features found within Microsoft purview
so the first is know your data
understand your data landscape and
identify important data across your
hybrid environment so one feature would
be sensitive information types this
identifies sensitive data by using
built-in or custom regular expressions
or a function it provides corroborative
evidence includes key words confidence
levels and proximity we have built-in
sensitive labels and you have custom
ones as well so then there's trainable
classifiers this identifies sensitive
data by using examples of the data
you're interested in rather than
identifying elements in the item so
pattern matching and you can use
built-in classifiers or train a
classifier with your own content say you
have trainable classifiers here for data
classification this is a graphical
identification of items in your
organization that have a sensitive label
a retention label or have been
classified you can also use this
information to gain insights into the
actions that your users are taking on
these items so that's the context
Explorer and the activity Explorer the
second part is protect your data so
apply flexible protection actions that
include encryption access restrictions
and visual markings say you have
sensitivity labels Azure information
protection unified labeling client
double key encryption Office 365 message
encryption service encryption with
customer key SharePoint information
rights manager Rights Management
connector Azure information protection
unified labeling scanner Microsoft
Defender for cloud apps and Microsoft
information protection SDK most of these
you won't need to know but will
definitely cover sensitivity labels then
we have prevent data loss so this
prevents accidental oversharing of
sensitive information here you have
Microsoft purview data loss prevention
and point data loss prevention Microsoft
compliance extension there's a Chrome
extension that does compliance for you
so it's built in your browser there's
the Microsoft purview data loss
prevention on premises scanner and
protects sensitive information in
Microsoft teams chat and channel
messages we'll definitely take a closer
look at Microsoft purview data loss
prevention later next we have Microsoft
purview data lifecycle management
formerly Microsoft information
governance which is a collection of
features to govern your data for
compliance or regulatory so for
Microsoft purview data lifecycle
management it keeps what you need and
deletes what you don't we have retention
policies and retention labels inactive
mailboxes archive mailboxes import
service for PSD files and for Microsoft
purview records management it manages
high value items for business legal or
regulatory record-keeping requirements
you have file plan retention labels for
individual items retention policies if
needed for Baseline retention and
disposition review and proof of
disposition so those are the four
domains in Microsoft purview information
protection govern your data is not
technically part of it as it's in the
data life cycle and record section but I
included it anyways
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the data
classification capabilities so sensitive
information types or classifications or
categories of data by sensitivity they
are pattern-based classifiers and they
have set patterns that can be used to
identify them so within the Microsoft
purview data classification feature you
can get a breakdown of the distribution
of sensitive info types so here imagine
you have a bunch of documents and you
said hey tell me what you found in these
documents and there it gives it kind of
a breakdown by type these types are
identified based on regular expression
or a function there are hundreds of
built-in information types for example
credit card numbers passport or
identification numbers bank account
numbers Health Service numbers IP
addresses Azure storage account keys and
driver's license numbers so it's a huge
list and so here's a list of some
sensitive info types these sensitive
information types are used in data loss
prevention policies sensitivity labels
retention labels Insider risk management
communication compliance and auto
labeling policies generally the first
thing you're going to do with your data
classification is to get your sensitive
information types and you can create
your own info types too so if there's
something that doesn't meet your needs
you'll have to write your own regular
expression but you can have whatever you
want another feature found in data
classification within Microsoft
purviewer trainable classifiers let's
talk about what training is and
classifiers are so a classifier is a
machine learning model that can take
records of data and classify or
categorize by applying a label from a
predetermined list of categories then
you have training and this is the act of
teaching a machine learning model how to
learn by providing it large amounts of
data that is already labeled it uses the
label data to tell if its predictions
are similar to the ones provided So
within Microsoft purview it has two
kinds of trainable classifiers three
train classifiers are ready to use
classifiers with five portraying
classifiers we'll talk about those five
in a moment you don't need to provide
any data used for training and it meets
many General use cases then you have
custom tradable classifiers this is when
you have your own kind of documents when
you have specific business documents but
you'll have to provide training data so
the five pre-trained classifiers or
resumes source code harassment profanity
and threat another feature in the data
classification within Microsoft purview
is content Explorer so this enables
administrators to gain visibility into
the content that has been summarized in
the overview pane it drills down to find
emails or documents that have been
labeled based on sensitive information
types sensitivity labels or retention
labels there are two roles that Grant
access to content Explorer you have
content Explorer list viewer and content
Explorer content viewer so the idea here
is you have broad categories on left
hand side so you see the three
categories sensitive info types
sensitivity labels and retention labels
and then what you'll do is Click into
one and then they'll have specific
actual items underneath and you click
into one of those and then from there
you can go on the right hand pane over
here you can go and explore different
documents and files to identify that
kind of information the other Explorer
here is the activity Explorer and this
helps discover which file labels were
changed and which files were modified so
it monitors label activity across
exchange SharePoint OneDrive and
endpoint devices a few activity types
that can be analyzed are file copied to
removable media file copy to network
share label applied and label change and
admins can use more than 30 filters for
data including location user sensitivity
label and retention label so here is a
great visual to help you get the idea so
here you have filters so activity
location user and the type of
sensitivity label and then you can see
it says label changed here in light blue
and you can see these labels were
applied in a darker tone of blue and
files copied to the cloud in dark orange
so it represents the amount of files or
labels according to the visual so it
helps you get an idea of what this does
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at sensitivity
labels so sensitivity labels allow you
to apply a label to your documents or
emails and the most common way is
through built-in drop down within Office
365 products so labels are customizable
admins can create different categories
specific to the organization such as
personal public confidential and highly
confidential they are clear text because
each label is stored in clear text in
the contents metadata third-party apps
and services can read it and then apply
their own protective actions if
necessary and they're persistent when
you apply a sensitivity label to content
the label is stored in the email or
document's metadata the label follows
the content including the protection
settings and this data is used to apply
and enforce policies so here we have an
example for Microsoft Word one for Excel
and here's one from Outlook the idea is
that you do your business as per usual
but you have to go ahead and classify
that information into a particular
sensitivity so sensitivity labeling
makes it easy to apply content marketing
or encryption content markings would be
like watermarks warnings that are
applied to the header and footer of a
document so notice here you can turn it
on and you can say add this watermark
with this customized text at this header
at this footer I think you can even
customize some of the colors but are
very limited but it does the job the
other one is encryption so apply
encryption and specify which users and
groups May decrypt and other fine-tuned
permissions so the idea is you would
turn the encryption on then you would
select the users groups Etc who could do
it then they have these broad categories
and so this particular one is for email
but here you choose which permissions
are allowed so are you allowed to view
the content can you save the email are
you allowed to reply to the email are
you allowed to forward the email so it's
very fine-tuned it's not just encryption
even though that's what it is so within
Microsoft purview under classification
you can see the distribution of
sensitive labels applied to documents
and emails or based on location so this
gives you a visual to help you
understand where these labels are
located on the left hand side shows what
sensitivity labels have been applied to
the content and then on the right here
it shows the location of where
sensitivity labels are applied so
sensitivity labels can be used to
provide protection settings that include
encryption and content markings protect
content in office apps across different
platforms and devices protect content in
third-party apps and services protect
containers extend sensitivity labels to
power bi extend sensitivity labels to
assets in Azure extend sensitivity
labels to third-party apps and services
and classify content without using any
protection settings so that sensitivity
labels
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at label
policies so in order to use sensitivity
labels they need to be published
alongside a label policy a label policy
determines who can use the label and
other conditions so the idea here is you
can specify which users or groups can
use these labels and then here are some
of the settings here so notice below
users must provide justification to
remove a label or lower classification
requires users to apply a label to their
email or document provides user with a
link to a custom help page so label
policies enable admins to choose the
users and groups that can see labels so
labels can be published of specific
user's distribution groups Microsoft 365
groups and Azure ID and more apply a
default label to all new emails and
documents that the specified users and
groups create users can always change
the default label if they believe the
document or email has been dislabeled
required justifications for label
changes so if a user wants to remove a
label or replace it admins can require
the user to provide a valid
justification to to complete the action
the user will be prompted to provide an
explanation for why the label should be
changed require users to apply a label
so mandatory labeling ensures a label is
applied before users can save their
documents send emails or create new
sites or groups and we have link users
to custom help Pages it helps users to
understand what the different labels
mean and how they should be used so
those are the sensitivity label policies
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at retention
policies and labels so retention labels
and policies help organizations to
manage and govern information by
ensuring content is kept only for a
required time and then permanently
deleted apply retention labels and
assigning retention policies helps
organizations comply proactively with
industry regulations and internal
policies that require content to be kept
for a minimum time reduce risk when
there's litigation or a security breach
by permanently deleting old content that
the organization is no longer required
to keep and it ensures users work only
with content that's current and relevant
to them when content has retention
settings assigned to it that content
remains in its original location so
retention settings work with the
following different workloads SharePoint
in OneDrive Microsoft teams jabber at
exchange so retention labels ensures
data is held for a specific duration to
meet a Regulatory Compliance or industry
best practices they are used to assign
retention settings at an item level such
as a folder document or email an email
or document can have only a single
retention label assigned to it at a time
so here you see the retention labels
applied to the which content retention
policies are used to assign the same
retention settings to content at a site
level or mailbox level a single policy
can be applied to multiple locations or
to specific locations or users items
inherit the retention settings from
their containers specified in the
retention policy and here you can see
the locations where the retention labels
are applied so this is similar to how
the sensitivity labels work
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're talking about records
management so what is records management
it's an organization's process of
managing an organization's information
throughout its life cycle record
management helps organization meeting
Regulatory Compliance or legal
requirements so a life cycle of a record
would look something like this it begins
with identifying then classifying
storing securing retrieving tracking
destroying and ends with preserving a
record represents labeled information or
content and its life cycle will be
managed so Microsoft purview records
management includes many features
including labeling content as a record
migrating and managing retention plans
with file plan manager establishing
retention and deletion policies within
the record label triggering event-based
retention reviewing and validating
disposition proof of Records deletion
exporting information about disposed
items and setting specific permissions
for record manager functions in the
organization label content applies the
following controls risk restrictions are
put in place to block certain activities
activities are logged and proof of
disposition is kept at the end of the
retention period so that's records
management
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at data loss
prevention so organizations need to
prevent data loss by detecting risky
behavior and preventing the improper
sharing of sensitive information
Microsoft purview data loss prevention
so DLP is a way to protect sensitive
information and prevent its
unintentional disclosure with DLP
policies admins can identify Monitor and
automatically protect sensitive
information across Microsoft 365
including OneDrive for business
SharePoint online Microsoft teams and
exchange online help users learn how
compliance Works without interrupting
their workflow admins can also view DLP
reports showing content that matches the
organization's DLP policies so DLP
policies are composed of conditions that
the content must match before the rule
is enforced actions that the admin wants
the rule to take automatically when
content that matches the conditions has
been found and locations where the
policy will be applied so a policy can
contain one or more rules and each rule
consists of conditions and actions at a
minimum for each rule when the
conditions are met the actions are taken
automatically rules can be grouped into
one policy to help simplify management
and Reporting so here's a diagram that
shows how multiple rules each with their
own conditions and actions are grouped
into a single policy so we have multiple
rules here rule one rule two Rule n Etc
and each of them have their own
conditions and actions and it's all
grouped into a single policy moving on
to inpoint data loss prevention so this
extends the activity monitoring and
protection capabilities of DLP to
sensitive items that are physically
stored on Windows 10 Windows 11 and Mac
OS devices and point DLP enables admins
to audit and manage activities that
users complete on sensitive content so
DLP capabilities have been extended to
Microsoft teams chat and channel
messages including messages in private
channels and with DLP administrators can
now Define policies that prevent users
from sharing sensitive information in a
team's chat session or Channel whether
it's in a message or a file so so that's
DLP
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
purview compliance portal also known as
Microsoft 365 compliance Center so this
provides easy access to the data and
tools you need to manage to your
organization's compliance needs to
access the compliance portal you will
need to have the following roles Global
administrator compliance administrator
or compliance data administrator some of
the key features of compliance portal
include compliance score audits activity
alerts solution catalog data
classification e-discovery Insider risk
management and Records management you
can access the compliance portal at
compliance.microsoft.com so the default
compliance portal home page contains
several cards including the compliance
manager card so this card leads you to
the Microsoft purview compliance manager
solution the solution catalog cards
include information protection and
governance these Solutions help
organizations classify protect and
retain your data where it lives in
wherever it goes examples include data
life cycle management and data loss
prevention then we have privacy this
helps you build a more privacy resilient
workplace we have Insider risk
management these Solutions help
organizations identify analyze and
remediate internal risks before they
cause harm examples include
communication compliance and Insider
risk management and we have Discovery
and respond so these Solutions help
organizations quickly find investigate
and respond with relevant data some
examples are audit and e-discovery we
briefly mentioned the Solutions catalog
before but it's great to reinforce that
knowledge and we have the active alerts
card which includes a summary of the
most active alerts in a link where
admins can view more detailed
information such as alert severity
status category and more so that's the
Microsoft purview compliance portal
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
purview compliance manager which is a
feature in the Microsoft purview
compliance portal that helps admins to
manage an organization's compliance
requirements compliance manager helps
simplify compliance and reduce Risk by
providing for built assessments based on
common Regional and Industry regulations
and standards including custom
assessments to meet compliance needs
unique to specific organizations
workflow capabilities that enable admins
to efficiently complete risk assessments
for the organization it provides
step-by-step Improvement actions that
admins can take to help meet regulations
and standards relevant to the
organization and it provides a
compliance score which is a calculation
that helps an organization understand
its overall compliance posture by
measuring how it's progressing with
Improvement actions so here you can see
the important sections like Improvement
actions Solutions assessments assessment
templates and your compliance score
which is currently at 69 percent and
we'll talk more about the compliance
score later so the compliance manager
has four key elements that you should
have a basic understanding of controls
assessments templates and Improvement
actions the first is control so a
control is a requirement of a regulation
standard or policy it defines how to
access and manage system configuration
organizational process and people
responsible for meeting a specific
requirement of Regulation standard or
policy so compliance manager tracks the
following types of controls Microsoft
managed controls these are controls for
Microsoft cloud services which Microsoft
is responsible for implementing there
are your controls also known as customer
managed controls these are implemented
and managed by the organization and
share controls so this is the
responsibility for implementing these
controls as shared by the organization
in Microsoft so the next key element are
templates and templates help admins to
quickly create assessments they can
modify these templates to create an
assessment optimized for their needs and
the next one is Improvement actions this
helps centralize compliance activities
each Improvement action provides
recommended guidance that's intended to
help organizations to align with data
protection regulations and standards the
last key element are assessments so an
assessment is a grouping of controls
from a specific regulation standard or
policy completing the actions within an
assessment helps to meet the
requirements of a standard regulation or
law clicking into an assessment will
give you a detailed list of actionable
controls as you can see in this image so
compliance manager provides many
benefits including translating
complicated regulations standards
company policies or other control
Frameworks into a simple language
providing access to a large variety of
out-of-the-box Assessments and custom
assessments to help organizations with
their unique compliance needs mapping
regulatory controls against recommended
Improvement actions providing
step-by-step guidance on how to
implement the solutions to meet
regulatory requirements and helping
admins and users to prioritize actions
that will have the highest impact on
their organizational compliance by
associating a score with each action so
that's compliance manager
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at compliance
score so compliance score measures
progress in completing recommended
Improvement actions within controls the
score helps organization to understand
its current compliance posture it also
helps organizations to prioritize
actions based on their potential to
reduce risk admins can get a breakdown
of the compliance score in the
compliance manager overview pane so
here's a visual showing the compliance
score breakdown and these are divided
into categories such as protect
information control access government
information and manage devices so the
overall compliance score is calculated
using scores that are assigned to
actions actions come in two types the
first is your improved actions which are
actions that the organization is
expected to manage and the second are
Microsoft actions and these are actions
that Microsoft manages for the
organization so actions are categorized
as mandatory discretionary preventative
detective or corrective the first is
mandatory so these are actions that
shouldn't be bypassed and we have
discretionary these actions depend on
the user's understanding and adhering to
a policy we'll talk about the other
three actions in the next slide since
they're in a subcategory so
organizations accumulate points for
every action completed and the
compliance score is shown as a
percentage representing all the actions
completed the visual here shows us the
list of improvement actions and for each
one that's completed you can gain points
which would increase your overall
compliance score so for this example
you're seeing plus 27 points for all the
Improvement actions you've completed so
back to the type of actions the
following are subcategories of actions
that can be classified as mandatory or
discretionary so preventative actions
are designed to handle specific risks
like using encryption to protect data at
rest if there were breaches or attacks
we have detective actions and these
actively monitor systems to identify
irregularities that could represent
risks or that can be used to detect
breaches or intrusions and there's
corrective actions so these help admins
to minimize the adverse effects of
security incidents by undertaking
corrective measures to reduce their
immediate effect were possibly even
reverse damage so that's compliance
score and its benefits towards an
organization
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Microsoft
purview Insider risk management which is
a solution that helps minimize internal
risks by enabling an organization to
detect investigate and act on risky and
malicious activities So within an
organization a broad range of internal
risks could occur from unethical
behavior and actions by employees and
managers some of these examples include
leaks of sensitive data and data
spillage confidentiality violations
intellectual property theft fraud
insider trading and Regulatory
Compliance violations so The Insider
risk management is centered around four
principles the first one is transparency
so balance user privacy versus
organization risk with privacy by Design
architecture the second one is
configurable so configurable policies
based on industry geographical and
business groups the third one is
integrated so there's integrated
workflow across Microsoft purview
Solutions and actionable so it provides
insights to enable user notifications
data investigations and user are
investigations so Insider risk
management in Microsoft purview uses the
following workflow to identify and
resolve internal risk activities and
compliance issues the first is policies
so these are created using predefined
templates and policy conditions that
Define what risk indicators are examined
in Microsoft 365 feature areas next we
have alerts so alerts are automatically
generated by risk indicators that match
policy conditions and are displayed in
the alerts dashboard this dashboard
enables a quick view of all alerts
needing review open alerts over time and
alert statistics for the organization
then we have triage which are new
activities that need investigation
automatically generate alerts that are
assigned and needs review status we have
investigate so cases are created for
alerts that require deeper review and
investigation of the details and
circumstances around the policy match
and the last one is action so reviewers
can immediately act to resolve issues
after they've been investigated or they
can collaborate with other risk
stakeholders in the organization actions
can be as simple as sending a
notification when employees accidentally
violate policy conditions in more
serious cases reviewers may need to
share The Insider risk management case
information with other reviewers in the
organization so that's The Insider Risk
Management Solutions to protect against
internal threats
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at e-discovery
which is a service found within
Microsoft purview so e-discovery stands
for electronic Discovery and this is the
process of identifying and delivering
electronic information that can be used
as evidence in legal cases so you can
use the discovery Tools in Microsoft 365
to search for content in exchange online
mailboxes Microsoft 365 groups Microsoft
teams SharePoint online OneDrive for
business sites Skype for business
conversations and jabber teams so
Microsoft purview provides us with three
Discovery Solutions the first one is
content search which lets you run a
search across content the second one is
e-discovery standard also known as core
Discovery is a workflow to search and
Export content and the last one is
e-discovery premium also known as
advanced ediscovery is an end-to-end
workflow to preserve collect review
analyze and Export content for internal
or external investigation and we'll talk
more about these three solutions in the
next slide sites so you Discovery
standard in Microsoft 365 provides a
basic e-discovery tool that
organizations can use to search and
Export content in Microsoft 365 in
office 365. you can use the discovery
standard to place an e-discovery hold on
content locations such as exchange
mailboxes SharePoint sites OneDrive
accounts and Microsoft teams nothing is
needed to deploy e-discovery standard
but there are some prerequisite tasks
that an IT admin and e-discovery manager
have to complete before your
organization can start using e-discovery
standard to search export and preserve
content so those requirements would be
things like the initial setup you'll
need to verify and assign appropriate
licenses assignee Discovery permissions
and create a Core e-discovery case and
from there you can use the create and
e-discovery hold feature search for
content and Export and download search
results so let's take a closer look here
at content search to perform a Content
search you can create a new search
specify the locations and provide the
keywords and conditions keep in mind
that if you leave the keywords blank it
will return all items with the
conditions so I just want you to notice
a few things here in the visuals here
you can create a new search and you can
search by ID list here we have our
location that we can turn on or off so
we have exchange Point SharePoint ad
exchange you could also search within a
hold so you have your keywords here you
can leave that blank and they have a
long list of conditions that you can
choose from here moving on to
e-discovery holds so a whole preserves
content that might be relevant to a
specific e-discovery case you can place
a hold in basically the same locations
we've mentioned before so exchange
mailboxes OneDrive for business
Microsoft teams Office 365 groups and
Yammer groups the content is preserved
until you remove the content location
from the holder until you delete the
hold and after you create an e-discovery
hold it may take up to 24 hours for the
hole to take effect taking a look at
e-discovery premium formerly Advanced
e-discovery so a discovery premium
workflow Builds on the existing
e-discovery standard workflow it is an
end-to-end workflow to preserve collect
review analyze and Export content that's
relevant to your organization's internal
and external investigations it also lets
legal teams manage the entire legal hold
notification workflow to communicate
with custodians involved in a case so
the built-in workflow of e-discovery
Premium aligns with the electronic
Discovery reference model edrm which is
a framework that outlines standards for
recovery and discovery of Digital Data
so the workflow would essentially look
something like this add custodians to a
case search custodial data sources for
data relevant to the case add data to a
review set review and analyze data in a
review set and Export and download case
data so that's the discovery and its
types of solutions and capabilities
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
purview auditing Solutions so what is an
audit it's the investigating of a
security events forensic investigations
internal investigations and compliance
obligations and audit would involve
capturing recording and retaining a
unified audit log so Microsoft 365 has
two auditing Solutions the first one is
audit standard formerly known as basic
audit and this is enabled by default it
provides thousands of searchable audit
events it has a 90-day audit record
retention you can export audit records
to a CSV file you can use the audit
Search tool in the Microsoft compliance
portal it provides access to audit logs
via Office 365 management activity API
you can also use it in Powershell with
the search Unified audit log commandlet
the second auditing solution is audit
premium formerly known as advanced audit
so this includes all of the audit
standard features but it provides audit
log retention policies it has longer
retention of audit records it has as
high value and crucial events and has
higher bandwidth to The Office 365
management activity API so those are the
Microsoft purview auditing Solutions
you'll need to know
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft
priva and privacy risk management so
organizations must adopt a privacy by
default policy to meet regulatory
requirements and build customer trust
Microsoft priva helps you achieve your
privacy goals by addressing issues like
helping employees adopt sound data
handling practices and training them to
spot and fix issues understanding the
potential risks and the amount and type
of personal data they store and share
and fulfilling data subject requests or
subject rights requests efficiently and
on time previous capabilities are
available through two solutions first we
have priva privacy risk management which
provides visibility into your
organization's data and policy templates
for reducing risks we'll talk more about
this in the next slide and there's
previous subject rights requests which
provides Automation and workflow tools
for fulfilling data requests so
Microsoft priva helps you understand the
data your organization stores by
automating discovery of personal data
assets and providing visualizations of
essential information the overview
dashboard provides an overall view into
your organization's data in Microsoft
365 privacy administrators can monitor
Trends and activities identify and
investigate potential risks involving
personal data and springboard into Key
activities like policy management or
subject rights request actions the data
profile page in preva provides a
snapshot view of the personal data your
organization stores in Microsoft 365 and
where it lives it also gives insight
into the types of data you store priv
evaluates your organization's data
stored in the following Microsoft 365
Services exchange online SharePoint
online OneDrive for business and
Microsoft teams privacy risk management
policies are meant to be internal guides
and can help you detect over exposed
personal data so that users can secure
it spot and limit transfers of personal
data across departments or Regional
borders and help users identify and
reduce the amount of unused personal
data that you store so that's Microsoft
private and the Privacy risk management
Concepts
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft's
privacy principles so Microsoft's
approach to privacy is built on the
following six principles the first one
is control so Microsoft States we will
put you in control of your privacy with
easy to use tools and Clear Choices the
second is transparency so we will be
transparent about data collection and
use so you can make informed decisions
the third is security we will protect
the data you entrust to us through
strong security and encryption the next
one is strong legal protections we will
respect your local privacy laws and
fight for legal protection of your
privacy as a fundamental human right the
fifth principle is no content-based
targeting we will not use your email
chat files or other personal content to
Target ads to you and the last principle
is benefits to you Microsoft States when
we do collect data we will use it to
benefit you and to make your experiences
better so those are Microsoft six
privacy principles briefly summarized
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're going to take a look at an
overview of Microsoft purview we'll be
going through the main components of the
Microsoft purview that you'll see on the
exam you can reach the Microsoft purview
compliance portal at
compliance.microsoft.com or
alternatively you can find it at the all
admin Center Page in the Microsoft 365
admin Center under the name compliance
so in general the Microsoft purview
compliance portal is for managing
compliance needs using Integrated
Solutions to help protect sensitive info
manage data life cycles reduce Insider
risks Safeguard personal data and more
one of the key components of the
Microsoft purview is the compliance
manager the compliance manager has a
feature called compliance score which
measures your progress in completing
recommended actions that help reduce
risks around data protection and
Regulatory standards Microsoft purview
calculates your compliance score based
on your organization beside the
compliance score the system tells you
the key Improvement actions you can
complete to improve the compliance score
let's click into it so here we see a
list of improvement actions that grant
us points that improve our compliance
score you can filter out regulations
Solutions groups categories and more to
find the Improvement action you're
interested in for example we can click
on enable self-service password reset so
here Microsoft recommends that your
organization enables self-service
password reset to allow users who have
either forgotten their password or whose
account has been locked out as a result
of malicious attempts so we'll click on
assign action we'll select a user and
assign the action to that user
next you'll need to click on launch now
now we're at the Azure active directory
admin Center password reset page so
we'll click on all to enable
self-service password reset and save the
changes to take effect the process of
calculating and updating the points in
compliance score may take up to 24 hours
so in the data classification section
the key things here would be sensitivity
labels these let you classify and
protect your organization's data while
making sure that user productivity and
their ability to collaborate isn't
hindered the next thing we'll look at
are reports and here you can view status
and trends for the compliance of your
Microsoft 365 devices data identities
apps and infrastructure the next thing
we'll look at is the solution catalog so
here you can discover learn about and
start using the intelligent compliance
and Risk Management Solutions available
to your organization the solution
catalog is categorized into cards and
further divided into subcategories based
on your needs for example we have
information protection and governance
then there are four other subcategories
such as data lifecycle management data
loss prevention information protection
and Records management there are a few
more listed below like privacy Insider
risk management and Discovery and
response another important component of
Microsoft purview is audit an audit can
be used when you need to find out if a
user deleted a document or if an admin
resets someone's password you can search
The Office 365 audit log to find out
what the users and admins in your
organization have been doing you'll be
able to find activity related to email
groups documents permissions directory
services and much more
next we have Microsoft purview
e-discovery in Microsoft purview
provides a basic e-discovery tool that
organizations can use to search and
Export content in Microsoft 365 in
office 365. you can also use the
discovery to place an e-discovery hold
on content locations such as exchange
mailboxes SharePoint sites OneDrive
accounts and Microsoft teams there are
three types of e-discovery standard
premium and user data search next we
have information protection you can
Implement capabilities for Microsoft
purview information protection to help
you discover classify and protect
sensitive information wherever it lives
or travels then we have Insider risk
management so this helps address risks
in the modern workplace you can detect
risky activity like sensitive data leaks
and theft security policy violations and
health record access get insights into
potential Insider risks an Insider risk
analytics helps quickly identify
potential risks in your org and
recommends policies to address them
collaborate on investigations seamless
workflows allowed to teams across your
org to work together on reviewing and
taking action on potential risks built
with privacy in mind protect users
privacy by pseudonymizing their names
across all Insider risk features so
those are some of the key important
components of Microsoft purview
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the pricing
models for Microsoft cloud services
starting with Cloud solution provider
abbreviated as CSP so the CSP program
helps you be more involved in your
customers businesses Beyond reselling
licenses and may include the following
benefits deeper customer engagements so
you can meet with customers on a regular
basis to gain a better understanding of
their business and demands you can get
increased profits so increasing your
support in Billing Services whether
directly or through a third party source
and opens up new revenue streams the CSP
program adds value you'll be able to
offer customers industry-specific
Solutions bundled with Microsoft
products and it provides managed
services so you'll be well positioned to
meet customer demand for managed
Services the CSP program provides a
pay-as-you-go subscription model with
per user per month pricing that enables
your business to scale up or down from
month to month as your needs change so
there are two models in the CSP program
there's the indirect model and the
direct Bill model for the indirect model
you may consider this model if you want
to provide more services to your
customers but need some infrastructure
support for services like billing the
indirect model is a two-tier selling
approach through indirect providers and
indirect resellers and direct providers
offer billing customer service and
technical support during the sales cycle
and post deal closing they handle a lot
of the backend processes enabling the
indirect reseller to focus on finding
and closing deals indirect providers
typically are large well-vetted
companies and the indirect model your
organization would likely be an indirect
reseller so indirect resellers are
responsible for finding customers and
selling and due to the support from
indirect providers you can focus on
selling and growing your customer base
looking at the direct model so you may
consider the CSP direct model if your
business already has or is intending to
develop appropriate sales billing and
support infrastructure in the direct
model partners by Microsoft products and
subscriptions directly from Microsoft
and sell them to their clients through
their own sales staff you should meet
the following requisites you'll require
an active Microsoft partner network ID
for the location you're enrolling in you
should have an existing customer support
infrastructure you'll require an
existing customer billing infrastructure
and you'll need funds to invest in
technical integration and support
Readiness so that's the Cloud solution
provider program and the two models
offered indirect model and direct build
model
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at another
pricing model for Microsoft cloud
services called Enterprise agreement so
the Microsoft Enterprise agreement is
designed for businesses looking to
license software and cloud services for
at least three years it provides
built-in savings ranging from 15 to 45
percent and the Enterprise agreement
offers the best value to organizations
with 500 or more users or devices so
it's really cost effective for more
larger sized organizations some of the
benefits of Enterprise agreement include
it's manageable so it gives you the
flexibility to buy cloud services and
software licenses under a single
organization-wide agreement you can
choose from Microsoft cloud services on
premises software or a mix of both and
migrate on your own terms the software
Assurance provides your company with
24x7 technical support planning services
and user and Technical Training and
Innovative Technologies and you can
manage licensing throughout the life of
your agreement with the help of a
Microsoft certified partner or a
Microsoft representative so that's the
Microsoft Enterprise agreement
[Music]
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we're
taking a look at the billing and billing
management options in Microsoft 365. so
a billing account is created when you
sign up to try or buy Microsoft products
at Cloud settings invoices payment
methods and purchases are all managed
through your billing account so these
are the current types of billing
accounts available in the Microsoft 365
admin Center the first one is the
Microsoft online services program so
this billing account is created when you
sign up for a Microsoft 365 subscription
directly the second one is the Microsoft
products and services agreement program
and this Billy account is created when
your organization signs an mpsa volume
licensing agreement to purchase software
and online services and the third one is
the Microsoft customer agreement so this
billing account is created when your
organization works with a Microsoft
representative and authorized partner or
purchases independently moving on to the
Bill management section so Microsoft 365
billing is managed from the Microsoft
365 admin Center you can manage the
subscriptions view billing statements
update payment methods change your
billing frequency and more in the admin
Center the following describes what can
be reviewed and modified in the
Microsoft 365 admin Center so you can
upgrade renew reactivate or cancel
subscriptions view the number of
purchase licenses and how many of those
licenses are assigned to individual
users for each service view a bill
invoice and pass billing statements you
can modify payment methods like updating
deleting replacing and adding other
types of payment modify your billing
frequency to monthly or annual billing
you can buy and manage other services or
features So based on your Microsoft 365
subscription you can add on things like
Microsoft Defender for Office 365
Microsoft teams calling plan and more
you can also manage your billing
notification emails and invoice
attachments like the list of email
accounts of who should receive automated
billing notifications so that's the
billing and Bill management options for
Microsoft 365.
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at billing
profiles in Microsoft 365. so a billing
profile contains a payment method
built-in information and other invoice
settings such as purchase order number
and email invoice preference you use a
billing profile to pay for the products
that you buy from Microsoft a billing
profile is automatically created when a
user makes a self-service purchase and
each billing profile is invoiced
separately so here's a table listing all
of the billing profile roles and
describing what they do roles on billing
profiles have permissions to control
purchases and you can view and manage
invoices so you would assign these roles
to users who track organize and pay
invoices for example you can assign
certain members of your Finance team the
role of a billing profile contributor
the first role we have is billing
profile owner so you can manage
everything for a billing profile the
second role is billing profile
contributor so you can manage everything
except permissions in a billing profile
the third role is billing profile reader
with this role you can read only view of
everything in a bill billing profile and
the last role is invoice manager this
role lets you view and pay bills and has
a read-only view of everything in a
billing profile so those are the billing
profiles in Microsoft 365.
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Microsoft
365 subscription plans Microsoft 365 has
a lot of different subscription plans to
Target the right people or organization
of any size and within the subscription
plans there may be different tier levels
so it can be a lot to take in but we'll
provide a brief overview of them so the
following list describes the
subscription Plans offered we have
Microsoft 365 for home and this consists
of Microsoft 365 personal and Microsoft
365 family personal is for a single
person with multiple devices and family
is for up to six people we have
Microsoft 365 education and this is for
educational institutions it has two
subscription plans for faculty and
students that include different features
A1 A3 and A5 Microsoft 365 government is
for government institutions and it has
two subscription plans that include
different features G1 G3 and G5
Microsoft 365 business is for small to
medium-sized organizations that have up
to 300 employees it has four
subscription tiers that include
different features Apps for business
business basic business standard and
business premium Microsoft 365 for
Frontline workers is designed to empower
Frontline workers and optimize Frontline
impact it has three subscription tiers
that include different features F1 F3
and F5 and we have Microsoft 365
Enterprise so this is for Enterprise
size organizations and has four
subscription tiers that include
different features apps for Enterprise
E3 E5 and F3 your organization can also
choose from three Office 365
subscription tiers E1 E3 and E5 so those
are the Microsoft 365 subscription plans
currently available and we'll go over
some of the important ones in Greater
detail in the next sections
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a closer look at
Microsoft 365 for business which is
designed for small and medium-sized
organizations it offers the full set of
Office 365 productivity tools and
includes security and device management
features however it doesn't include some
of the more advanced information
protection compliance or analytics tools
available to Enterprise subscribers it's
typically designed for organizations
that need up to 300 licenses and as we
mentioned before there's four available
plans for Microsoft 365 for business so
we have apps for business business basic
business standard and business premium
so looking at a general overview of what
each plan has to offer starting off with
the lowest cost plan we have Microsoft
365 business basic and so this provides
chat call meet up to 300 attendees
weapon mobile versions of office apps
one terabyte of cloud storage business
class email Standard Security and
anytime phone and web support the apps
and services in this plan include Word
Excel PowerPoint teams Outlook Exchange
OneDrive and SharePoint the next plant
is Microsoft 365 Apps for business and
this has essentially everything in
business basic including desktop
versions of office apps with premium
features but it doesn't include things
like business class email it also has
apps and services like access PC only
and publisher Microsoft 365 business
standard has everything in business
basic including desktop versions of
office apps with premium features easily
host webinars attendee registration and
Reporting tools and manage customer
appointments the last plant available is
Microsoft 365 business premium which is
the most expensive plan and this is
everything in business standard
including security features like
Advanced security access and data
control and cyber threat protection it
also has apps and services like InTune
and Azure information protection so
that's all the Microsoft 365 for
business subscriptions available and the
features each of them include
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a closer look at
Microsoft 365 Enterprise subscription
plans and these plans provide Enterprise
class services to organizations that
want a productivity solution that
includes robust threat Protection
security compliance and analytics
features like we briefly mentioned
before there are three available plans
for Microsoft 365 Enterprise there's E3
E5 and F3 which is formerly F1 so the E5
plan is the most expensive plan and it
includes all the same features as E3 but
it also includes the latest Advanced
threat Protection security and
collaboration tools and the F3 is
designed for first-line workers through
purpose-built tools and resources that
allow them to do their best work and
here you can see the prices of each
subscription plan in a brief summary of
what they offer so here's a table
listing all of the features included in
each plan you can see that all the plans
fully include M365 apps like PowerPoint
Word and Excel email and calendar
features like Outlook and exchange
device and app manage management
features like Windows social and
internet features like SharePoint and
Yammer files and content features like
OneDrive in stream Work Management
features like planner to do and power
apps and Security Management that E3 and
F3 only partially includes things like
meets and voice identity and access
management information protection and
compliance management so that's the
Microsoft 365 Enterprise plans
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at Microsoft 365
licenses so what is a license well a
license allows your users to use the
features and services included in the
subscription plan Microsoft 365 products
and services are available as user
subscription licenses abbreviated as
usls and are licensed on a per user
basis so the following list describes
the options that are available the first
option are full usls and these are for
new customers who haven't previously
purchased Microsoft products and
services the second option or ad on usls
and these are for on-premises software
customers who want to add Microsoft 365
Cloud products and services the third
option are from saus and these are for
on-premises software Assurance customers
that want to transition to the cloud the
last option we have are step up usls and
these are for customers who want to
upgrade the level of their service and
so each user accessing Microsoft 365
products and services is required to be
assigned to USL administrators manage
licenses in in the Microsoft 365 admin
Center they can assign the licenses to
individual user or guest accounts now
taking a look at the Microsoft 365
add-on licensing options so Microsoft
365 business plans have add-ons that you
can purchase for your subscriptions and
these add-ons provide more capabilities
to enhance your subscription there are
currently two types of add-ons available
the first type of add-ons are
traditional add-ons and these are linked
to a specific subscription and if you
cancel the subscription the linked
add-on is also canceled the second typer
Standalone add-ons and these appear as a
separate subscription on the your
products page within the Microsoft 365
admin Center they have their own
expiration date and are managed the same
way you would any other subscription so
those are the Microsoft 365 licenses and
add-on options
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Microsoft
365 service life cycle so typically a
product or service life cycle has three
phases the first phase is private
preview then the second phase is public
preview and the third phase is General
availability abbreviated as GA and when
a product or a service retires it
reaches the phase end of support so
let's take a closer look at these three
phases including the end of support
looking at private preview so in this
phase Microsoft May release a product or
service to a limited number of users to
test and evaluate new features or
functionality this does not come with
formal support and users are allowed to
sign up to be members but the preview
releases it made available to the public
next we have public preview and in this
phase Microsoft typically releases
public previews of products and services
before their General availability
release to receive feedback from a broad
range of users this phase allows users
to explore and test upcoming
functionality and users may also receive
some limited support depending on the
product or service service moving on to
General availability so after the public
preview is completed Microsoft releases
the product or service the product or
service now becomes available to all
customers with formal support known as
the release version the products and
services in this phase have been through
a full development and test life cycle
to ensure stability and reliability and
with Microsoft 365 new features are
added to the products and services
periodically taking a look at end of
support So eventually older products or
retired Services can no longer be
supported and these products and
services will reach the end of support
once a product or service reaches end of
support it will no longer receive
updates or assisted support customers
are encouraged to migrate to the latest
version of the product or service so
that's the Microsoft 365 service life
cycle
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Modern
Life Cycle policy for Microsoft 365. so
Microsoft 365 is covered by the Modern
Life Cycle policy and this covers
products and services that are serviced
and supported continuously if the
following conditions are met products
and services governed by the Modern Life
Cycle policy will be supported the first
condition states that customers are to
stay current as per the servicing and
system requirements published for the
product or service stay current means
that customers accept and apply all
servicing updates for their products and
services the second condition states
that customers must be licensed to use
the product or service and the last
condition states that Microsoft must
currently offer support for the product
or service also under the Modern Life
Cycle policy Microsoft gives a minimum
of 12 months notice before ending
support for products so that's a quick
overview of the Modern Life Cycle policy
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Microsoft
365 roadmap portal which is typically
used for organizations to plan for the
future Microsoft regularly includes
updates for its products and services in
the Microsoft 365 roadmap the roadmap is
the central location for business
decision makers at professionals and
anyone else who's interested to see
what's coming next it was created to
help you plan communicate changes and
take full advantage of your Microsoft
365 subscription so the visual on the
right simply shows the layout of the
Microsoft 365 roadmap here you can
search for specific items you're
interested in filter the items based on
product release phase platform and More
You could also view which items are
currently in development the ones that
are rolling out and launched so the
roadmap displays feature cards that
include the title status release dates
product category platform and Cloud
instance the roadmap also groups the
features into three update phases the
first update phase is called in
development the second is rolling out
and the last phase is lodged the
following list describes what the
Microsoft 365 roadmap allows you to do
you can search by product keyword or
feature ID filter by product release
phase Cloud instance platform or new or
updated sort by General availability
date or newest to oldest it lets you
download the current features in
development as a CSV file you can view
additional information about each update
use the RSS feed to be notified of
feature updates in real time and you can
share an entire roadmap page or email a
single feature to find out what features
and functionality are coming navigate to
microsoft.com
www.microsoft 365 roadmap
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Microsoft
roadmap portal we'll be looking at some
of the key features and things you can
find in the Microsoft roadmap portal so
in general the Microsoft 365 roadmap
lists updates that are currently planned
for applicable subscriber and provides
estimated release dates and descriptions
for commercial features you can get the
latest updates on their Best in Class
productivity apps and intelligent cloud
services so on this page you can search
for a specific item that you're
interested in you can filter the items
below to however you want and the
products filter there is a very large
list of Microsoft products you can
choose from such as Microsoft 365
Microsoft 365 admin Center Microsoft 365
compliance Center teams and many more
you can filter based on release phase
such as general availability or targeted
release you can also filter based on the
type of platforms such as Android
desktop iOS mac and more there's also
the cloud instance and new or updated
ones too there's the option to filter
based on ethereum development which are
updates that are currently in
development and testing rolling out
which are updates that are beginning to
roll out and are not yet available to
all applicable customers or launched
which are fully released updates that
are now generally available for
applicable customers you can filter in
any sort of combination you prefer so
let's look at one example here so this
is called Microsoft 365 admin Center
groups group driven membership
management we can see that this is
currently in development so you'll be
given a bunch of information on this
specific update this includes a
description of the update the feature ID
83113 the data was added to roadmap and
the data was last modified it'll provide
you with the product Microsoft 365 admin
Center the Cloud instances GCC High DOD
GCC worldwide platform webbit and
release phase General availability so
there's a large list of updates here and
you can narrow it down using filters
according to your preferences so that's
a quick overview of the Microsoft 365
roadmap portal
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the Support
options for Microsoft 365 services so
administrators and users in your
organization may have difficulty
resolving issues on their own it's
reassuring to know that they can get
help with Microsoft 365 Services anytime
they need it through a variety of
Support options the support option
chosen to deal with a particular issue
depends on the tool or service where the
issue has arisen the type of
subscription your organization uses and
the kind of support your organization
needs so here's a list of ways your
organization can get access to support
the first is through community-based
support this is where the Microsoft 365
Tech Community provides community-based
support for your organization allowing
you to collaborate with others and solve
challenges then we have proactive
support so your organization can install
the Microsoft support and recovery
assistant to help identify Problems by
running tests and offer the best
solution for those problems then we have
web chat email and phone support So your
organization can submit issues to
Microsoft support for technical billing
and subscription support via email
online web chat or phone we have
pre-sale support your organization is
provided with assistance on subscription
features benefits and your purchasing
decision for Microsoft 365 Services then
there's Fast Track This is where your
organization can connect with expert
Microsoft Engineers project managers and
resources to help deploy Microsoft 365
services and resolve issues then we have
Premier support for Microsoft 365. so
your Enterprise organization can receive
on-site support a dedicated technical
account manager and access to advisory
Services the last support option is you
can get support through a Microsoft
partner this is where your organization
can get support directly through a
certified Microsoft 365 partner so
that's the Support options for Microsoft
365 services
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how to create
a support request so if you need help
with using Microsoft 365 you can create
a support request through the Microsoft
365 admin Center here is a visual
showing the Microsoft 365 admin Center
and here you would navigate to the
support section and click on new service
requests to create one the second visual
here simply shows the service request
history so you would click on view
service requests and you can see the
history of what service requests you
submitted before and you can check on
the status of the service requests for
any replies so the following steps
describe how to create a support request
as an administrator the first step is to
sign into the Microsoft 365 admin center
with your Microsoft 365 admin account in
the left navigation menu select show all
to expand the rest of the options select
support to expand the Support options
select new service request so you've
seen these steps so far from the visuals
on the previous slide now on the right a
support window will open where you can
enter your support question and view the
results that's the visual on the right
here showing it and if the recommended
instructions or articles don't answer
your questions select on the headset
iCloud at the top or select contact
support at the bottom to contact
technical support still in the required
information like title description
preferred contact method Etc and select
contact me and a support agent will
contact you so those are the
instructions on how to create a support
request
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the service
level agreement Concepts abbreviated as
SLA in Microsoft 365. so Microsoft 365
Services guarantees level of service for
your organization in a detailed legal
agreement referred to as a service level
agreement Microsoft details its
commitment to provide and maintain
agreed service levels for M365 Services
through its Microsoft online services
agreement your organization can also
take advantage of the service level
agreement with your cloud service
provider note that the guarantees of
service provided for Microsoft 365
services will vary between cloud service
providers so Microsoft's online service
level agreement introduces several
Concepts the first one is incident and
this is a set of events or single event
that results in downtime the second one
is uptime this is the total time your
services are functional the next one is
downtime and the definition of downtime
depends on the relevant service for
example with Microsoft teams any period
of time where users are unable to
initiate online meetings see present
statuses or unable to instant messages
considered downtime your downtime
reduces the total time your services are
functional then we have claim so a claim
raises information about an incident and
your organization is responsible for
submitting a claim on an incident the
next concept is an important one called
service credit and so service credits
are submitted by the organization's
admin if the claim is successfully
approved by Microsoft your organization
will receive service credits the service
credit will be the percentage of the
total monthly fees your organization
paid for the month where you experience
downtime then we have service level and
this is the performance metric set forth
in the SLA that Microsoft agrees to meet
in the delivery of the services and the
last concept is uptime agreement and the
uptime agreement is defined by the
monthly uptime percentage which we'll
explain a bit more in the next slide so
downtime is any period of time when
office applications are put into reduced
functionality mode due to an issue with
Office 365 activation and the monthly
uptime percentage is typically
calculated using the following formula
but this may not apply to every service
so user minutes minus downtime divided
by user minutes times 100 where downtime
is measured in user minutes that is for
each month downtime is the sum of the
length of each incident that occurs
during that month multiplied by the
number of users impacted by that
incident the percentage of service
credit your organization can receive is
linked to your monthly uptime percentage
for example if downtime has resulted in
a monthly uptime percentage lower than
95 percent your organization could
receive a 100 percent service credit and
the table here describes the monthly
uptime percentage and corresponding
service credit so if the monthly uptime
percentage is less than 99.9 percent you
could get 25 service credit if the
monthly uptime percentage is less than
99 you could get 50 service credit and
if it's less than 95 percent you could
get 100 service credit so your
organization should always review all
service level agreements and ask
questions including the following list
if you're using a cloud service provider
how does it determine service levels and
whether they're achieved or not who is
responsible for reports how can your
organization access reports are there
any exceptions in the agreement what
does the agreement say about both
unexpected and scheduled maintenance
what does the agreement say about what
happens if your infrastructure goes down
because of an attack what about natural
disasters and other situations outside
of your control does the agreement cover
not Microsoft service or system failures
what are the limits to the cloud service
provider's liability in the agreement so
that's the overview of SLA
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at the health
status of Microsoft 365 services so the
Microsoft 365 admin Center allows your
organization's administrators to see the
current health status of each of your
Microsoft 365 services and tenants they
can view the history of services that
have been affected in the last 30 days
and information about current outages or
disruptions to Services viewing the
health can help you figure out whether
you're dealing with a known issue that
has a solution in progress you can go to
Select Health under the left navigation
pane then service Health to access it so
if your organization is experiencing a
service issue your administrators can
report it by going to reported issues
select report and issue and complete a
short form administrators can view
specific details about service issues
selecting incidents or advisories your
organization can set up notifications
for any new incidents or for updates to
any active incidents that might affect
your organization Microsoft provides two
different types of notifications the
first one is unplanned downtime this is
where in incident has caused a service
to become unresponsive or unavailable
and the second one is plan maintenance
where Microsoft regularly carries out
service updates to the software and
infrastructure that runs Services
Microsoft also analyzes unplanned
service incidents for you through
post-incident reviews you'll receive a
preliminary review within the first two
days of incident resolution and a final
review within five business days the
final post incident reviews will detail
the following information how you might
have been impacted and how the user
experience was impacted a date and time
breakdown detailing when an incident
started and when it was resolved and an
analysis of the root cause and what
actions are to be carried out to prevent
the incident in the future so your
organization can keep track of the
health status of services in different
ways first we have admin app this lets
you view and stay up to date with the
health status of the services on the go
then we have Microsoft System enter
which allows you to view all service
Communications from within system center
if your organization has the Office 365
management pack and API you can use the
Office 365 service Communications API to
create or use tools that can connect and
monitor the service status for you in
real time to protect and keep your
organization's data available Microsoft
does the following data storage
redundancy so Microsoft stores your data
through multiple levels of redundancy
using data replication and secure data
protection capabilities monitoring data
so your databases are monitored for you
and your data is monitored packet loss
latencies and queries and more
preventative measures so Microsoft
regularly carries out checks for
database consistency reviews of error
logs and more so that's an overview of
the health status of Microsoft 365
services
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look at how
organizations can communicate with
Microsoft about product and service
improvements so Microsoft has various
channels for you to submit feedback
about Microsoft 365 products and
services for example if you're using
feedback which is the community feedback
web portal you can submit new feedback
directly within the web portal you can
participate in existing feedback by
voting or commenting on existing topics
and you can review feedback you've
submitted it's impact and Status by
viewing official responses from the
Microsoft product teams so the following
list describes the ways you can
communicate directly with Microsoft
feedback and product experiences Windows
feedback Hub Microsoft Tech Community
Microsoft store and user voice forums
use these sites to share your ideas and
contribute to the Improvement of
Microsoft products and services for your
company and other users around the world
taking a look at feedback in Greater
detail so the community feedback portal
lets you tell Microsoft about any
problems you run into while using
Microsoft 365 Community feedback allows
you to browse or vote on feedback from
the community community feedback is
publicly displayed within different
forums and your username will be
displayed by feedback you submit
publicly or comments you provide looking
at the visual here you can select which
service you're interested in or have
feedback for and click into it in this
case it's Microsoft teams and so you'll
see lots of posts from the community
about improvements and feedback and you
can send your own feedback as well
navigate to
feedbackportal.microsoft.com to access
it taking a closer look on submitting
feedback selecting a form allows you to
see all feedback related to that product
and you can upvote or comment on
feedback that matches yours if you don't
see feedback that is similar to your own
you can submit new feedback through the
portal itself here are some guidelines
for good feedback make your title
concise and descriptive this will help
others find and upvote your feedback
send one thought per feedback
information about your device operating
system and applications are
automatically included in each reported
feedback back taking a look at the
Microsoft Tech Community which is a
place to interact with it Pros
developers and end users along with
Microsoft the focus of the site was
initially on Office 365 but now
encompasses Azure Enterprise Mobility
Plus security and many other Microsoft
Technologies communities are for
different Microsoft products and
solutions members can join communities
that interest them navigate to
techcommunity.microsoft.com to access it
here are some of the benefits of
participating in the Microsoft Tech
Community influence Microsoft with
feedback constructive comments and ideas
help other members with Solutions or
insights on problems learn about best
practices new features and get the
latest information from Microsoft ask
questions and get help from peers access
content from special events like
Microsoft ignite and the Microsoft tech
Summit take part in online events such
as ask Microsoft anything and get
recognition for overall contributions to
the community with member of the week or
ranks like super contributor so that's
how you can share feedback on Microsoft
365 services for improvements and more
[Music]
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we're
taking a look at how to create and
manage technical support cases in the
Microsoft 365 admin Center so on the
left pane of the Microsoft 365 admin
Center portal click on support then
click on new service request on the how
can we help page provide a description
of your problem and the system will
provide a list of Articles which could
potentially apply to your issue or help
solve them the autocomplete function of
the search box will pop up the most
relevant articles for your case or in
some cases a Diagnostics wizard May pop
up to further guide you through issue
resolution in this example we are
requesting support because we are having
issues and can't install office this
pops up a run diagnostic section and
provides an article on how to resolve
this issue it provides an explanation on
the topic in a step-by-step guide on how
to resolve the issue
it also provides recommended articles at
the end of The Help window if the
article suggests it does not meet your
needs if the automated help is not
sufficient you can click on the headset
icon on the top to request assistance
from a support agent and open a support
case in this case you must provide a
title and description of your case
you must also provide a telephone number
and contact email address
and consent to the recording of calls or
not afterwards
you should choose your preferred method
of communication there are four options
available
chat with a support agent phone with a
response time of within five hours email
with a response time of within one hour
or schedule a callback for a specific
date and time we'll go with the option
email since it's the most convenient for
us you can optionally add attachments to
further assist the support agents in
troubleshooting your case you have
Regional settings where you can provide
a time zone and optionally an
alternative language of communication
other than English
after you have provided all information
for your new technical case click on the
contact me button
this will create a new unique support
case ID and you should receive
confirmation through email to view
service requests to view the status of
the service requests you have already
created browse to support view service
requests from this page it provides a
list of all your existing service
requests as well as your previous
service requests you can export all
service requests and manage existing
service requests by reviewing existing
notes or by adding new notes as a
response to an action item which has
been identified by the support agents
this page is the best way to track the
progress of your support cases and see
the full history of changes carried out
while troubleshooting your issue so
that's how you can create and manage
technical support cases in the Microsoft
365 admin Center